e
now that attorney Williams is present we
may
sorry just a little bit from me to the
committee but but uh all my favorite
friends can listen in on this um today
we start with what I call the beauty
pageant and that's where we have members
from the Departments that uh frequently
come before us come before us in a more
convivial way to introduce themselves uh
I
will share their nicknames that I have
for them and things like that we are
going to start this afternoon in the
hearings and we're going to start sharp
at 1 so please be here 12:55 and the
reason is because the person who is the
Prime sponsor of the 1:00 Bill also has
another bill to present a few minutes
later this is the price of
popularity I will when I find them
introduce our committee assistant and
researcher just a few words about how we
Pro seed in hearings for those of you
who are new if you wish to speak to a
witness please put your hand up if I
don't see your hand uh somebody else can
kind of point but uh we worked at
yes I bought one of those extended hands
that you know you scratch yourself
within the shower because I could never
see representative Raymond down the end
so I finally concluded you can always
move her you know so here she is but if
you put your hand up wait to be
recognized
and what you say next is thank you Mr
chairman uh chairman is my preferred uh
pronoun I sit on my chair but I am the
chairman uh other people who pinch hit
for me may have different ways they wish
to be addressed and that's fine so
you'll say Thank you Mr chairman and
then turn to the witness and say thank
you for taking my question it is a
question it's not a speech there's time
for that later you don't set up your
question with a preliminary remark you
simply ask a question we are here to
elicit information there will be times
for us to give our opinions to each
other do not cross-examine the witness
uh if you come really close believe me I
have too and uh this isn't
Congress if you are a sponsor or
co-sponsor of one of the bills that we
will be hearing here you have a
choice either you can be a witness and
testify or you can be a member of the
committee to ask other Witnesses
questions you cannot do
both so if you decide decide to start
asking Witnesses a question and then you
decide oh I'd love to go and test it's
other if you ask a question and you
think that that was only a partial
answer being given you can ask for
followup and usually the signal is like
that wait for me to say yes go ahead and
follow
up if we are in a hearing where a lot of
people have signed the pink card to
speak I may impose a three-minute
rule people say that's not fair I took a
day off from work to get here one of the
best speeches I've heard from a witness
lasted 47 seconds it had all the
information it was clear it was precise
if it is a paragraph cut it down to a
sentence if it's a sentence cut it down
to a word or a phrase it can be done a
lot can be said in 3 minutes and quite
frankly those of us who have mild add
stop listening after 3 minutes anyway so
you're not helping yourself
um at three
minutes I will make some kind of a
comment you got to wrap it up which
means I'll give you about 15 seconds to
wrap it up if you're testifying and at
the end of that I'll cut you off I
control everyone's mics from right
here uh when we bring in members of an
agency or a department it isn't a three
minute rule for them they can make the
Witnesses exing
bills right after we've had a hearing it
is possible to vote on that bill right
then many of us find that helpful
because if we wait a month we've pretty
well forgotten already what we've heard
so right after it however I will check
with my ranking me and Deputy ranking
member um what they think and this
worked really well the last couple of
years if it looks like it's going to be
a close vote and one side or the other
is short a person that would make a
difference in what we recommend I won't
exect the bill at that time we'll
advertise when it will happen if we
think that we need a discussion further
or that somebody might bring in an
amendment we won't EXA the bill right
away we will usually only exec those
bills where it's pretty clear all of us
or most of us are on board with what
we've
got the history of this committee going
back a
ways was not good many people believed
that they were harmed by an extremely
unfair and corrupt judicial
system and therefore we're going to fix
them we're going to run for office ask
to be put on this committee and since
very few people wanted to be that was
pretty much assured and then we're going
to fight and as a result very little
actually got
done it got to the point where in
2016 in that day when we vote on house
rules Speaker of the House Shan Jasper
was going to shut this committee down
well the house overruled him but you got
to know the idea of shutting a committee
down has to say there have been some
problems my
attitude is that we're not here to gang
up against we're here to gang up against
problems not people not the department
not the Judiciary not that Bureau even
when we disagree we are not to be
disagreeable we will work together I
find most people respond to that and as
happen if you make a motion when we are
voting I move OTP autopass or itl
inexpedient to legislate you get a
reward for making that motion you get to
write the committee report that will
appear in the calendar those reports are
due before you leave that day they go to
the they go to me I have to proof read
them then they go to the clerk one or
disposal many people have asked the
question will there be a two-year
extension on the special committee on
the Family Division of Circuit Court you
may remember chairman Lynn's Judiciary
Committee and my children in family law
committee each named five people to this
10p person panel and we got a lot done I
think again because we tried to work
with and not against the Judiciary we
tried to identify problems and it was a
wonderful relationship we picked a lot
of lwh hanging fruit could we Mr Speaker
go further up the tree and his answer
was no but no he is not going to
reconstitute that
committee but he says as chair of a
committee I can appoint a subcommittee
and I could appoint a subcommittee of
whatever number to look at some of these
issues in effect keep the thing going so
if this sounds something you are
interested in if you would like to be on
such a subcommittee think about it we
won't be doing this for 6 eight weeks at
the earliest think about it think about
what issues in the judicial system
Family Court you think think could use
some
attention so any questions on process or
committee Democrats you can ask your
ranking member and Deputy ranking member
Republicans you can ask me or the vice
chair and so on with that flown in at
Great
expense
is Attorney John Williams I periodically
inadvertently insult him by calling him
represent resentative he knows I don't
mean any ill by that and U attorney
Williams if you would come up tell us
who you are what you do and
department chairman Pearson good morning
and for the record my name is John
Williams I am the legislative director
of Affairs of legislative affairs
director uh for the Department of Health
and services and I have uh actually a uh
history with this committee and and a
good one uh I started with this uh
working uh with the Department back in
1998 and I found myself soon here prior
to the turn of the century um and this
was my first in favorite committee I was
with a program area one that you'll hear
from today uh it was then the division
for child supp services now it's under
the division for economic stability
Bureau of Child Support Services uh I've
had the pleasure of serving amongst uh
with this committee uh working with you
on important initiatives going all the
way back to Pat ding um Ed Moran and
also the wonderful uh Kimberly rice who
through their leadership uh has done
extraordinary things over the year and I
have the pleasure of working with you
chairman Pearson uh and as well as our
staff here today who are who are
prepared to present I do have one of
your favorite um items which is our
devil cider devil sided and you can
imagine on our three-day weekend for us
to be able to get this to the printer so
you have good stock uh we do have this
this is the legislative contact list for
the Department it has key um uh staff
both the directors the associate
commissioner commissioner Deputy
Commissioner uh and also um very
importantly to you our legislative
Liaisons I could not do the incredible
work that the department does without
the team effort uh from those uh that I
you will see from behind me so with that
with no further Ado I will turn it back
over to you uh chair and Pearson I will
certainly um hand these out and I
believe the first item uh for
presentation before your committee is
going to be the division for child
excuse me the Bureau of Child Support
Services is going to be first followed
by the division for children youth and
family and then ALS after that uh the
Bureau of children's Behavioral Health
and they're very well spoken they'll do
a phenomenal job and I just want to
thank you all as we started on probably
the coldest day I can ever remember
coming to a legislative hearing here and
I'm I'm meaning on the outside not on
the inside of the building so thank you
so much Council your heart should be
warmed to know that it looks like the
speaker's office will name the people to
DHHS oversight committee so Friday at 1
we're still
thank you Mr chairman uh my name is
attorney Matthew Hayes I'm a Staff
attorney in legislative liaison for the
Bureau of Child Support Services and I
have with me
today uh our bureau chief Lisa
dekowski um we're happy to answer any
questions the committee has but we
presented a a brief overview of our
agency and I'm going to let her present
that and um we have some copies for our
well this uh sheet that is being was
passed around from attorney Williams on
very expensive card stock uh is who you
need to know and how you can find them
and this is helpful committee members if
you have a constituent who has a
question who over there in the big
department
should I call this will be helpful to
you so tell me again so I can find it on
the card um the name of your
group Bureau of Child Support Services
child support services okay and my name
is Matthew Hayes
right it might also be under division of
economic
stability let's just wait a second and
find a division of economic
stability uh okay yeah second side right
hand at least halfway down we are good
thank
you good morning everyone good morning
uh Mr chairman and members of the
committee as um attorney Hayes indicated
my name is Lisa decowski and I am the
bureau chief for the Bureau of Child
Support Services I've had the pleasure
of being in this position for several
years now um however I've been with the
child support program for almost 11
years now with the Department of Health
and Human Services for over 20 years um
well we have prepared for you just a
short uh slide deck of some general
information about our Bureau who we are
and what we do and the services that we
provide um certainly our contact
information is available to you as
attorney Hayes mentioned we are here for
you as a resource
please feel free to reach out to us ask
we'd be happy to answer any questions
that you may have generally about our
child support program here in New
Hampshire um and certainly as uh
providing this information to you today
if you have any questions please let us
know uh we'd be happy to try to answer
those for you we are not hoping to take
a lot of your time today we understand
you have a lot uh to uh cover today um
so uh the handout should complement the
information um that we uh hope to share
with you and act as a
resource I just want to begin uh with
the mission of the child support program
which is to encourage responsible
parenting Family self-sufficiency and
Child well-being and we do that by
providing services to help locate
parents uh who may be absent from their
family household assist in establishing
paternity or legal fatherhood for
children uh we help families to
establish and or modify support orders
uh which include child and medical
support orders and we also help families
enforce those court-ordered obligations
when it is necessary um so the child
support program really achieves uh seeks
to achieve positive outcomes for
children um by addressing the needs and
the responsibilities of parents to help
support them you know the child's of
children need both parents um and
support in many ways and our program is
designed to try to assist families in
many different
circumstances but our largest
contribution is to help um provide
income for families to support their
economic Mobility by collecting and
dispersing child support payments um and
in doing so we
uh engage with both parents um and serve
both um parents in the household uh
through the services we provide helping
families receive child support really is
an as income reduces um child poverty
and promotes self-sufficiency so in
helping families address some of the
economic barriers that they may have to
compliance we are be better able to uh
assist the whole family um and we do
that by partnering with a number of
stakeholders and community services
Community so our Bureau of Child Support
Services as mentioned is within the
Department of Health and Human Services
uh we lie within the division of
economic stability um and we are one of
the large the child support program in
general is one of the largest income
support and anti high-poverty programs
for families we have here and families
um we provide services to families of
children whose parents or caretaker do
not reside in the same household
together um and we um collect and
enforce on court ordered obligations for
child support um and we provide uh both
instate and outof state services and in
some circumstances we work with our
International Partners as well as some
tribal communities as well so either
parent can apply for our services um we
collect and distribute private not
government funds to families to help pay
for their basic needs and we are always
uh trying to engage and assist parents
who are willing and able or unable to
support their children and only work to
uh enforce the responsibil ities of
unwilling so we um provide our service
delivery that we have is available
Statewide we provide services um
throughout within all of our district
offices we are there to help families um
you know nationally the child support
program uh collects approximately 29.6
billion nationally
uh for families and 97% of those uh
funds that we collect go directly to
families um so here in New Hampshire uh
in uh fiscal year 2023 our program
dispersed about $76 million to the
families that we are
servicing and much of that is uh often
um about
90ish perc of that goes directly to the
families and about 75% of the the income
that we collect is done uh through an
income withholding order here in our
state so we have um we work very closely
with our court systems we work very
closely with our employers here in New
Hampshire both of which play a vital
role to helping a secure income for
families here in our state our governing
Authority is
um uh we operate under an approved state
plan uh for uh the title Roman numeral
4D or part D of the Social Security Act
and uh under our uh approved plan is how
our program uh operates the services
that we are required to provide as a 4D
child support program and you know
through the last 50 years so the Social
Security Act act uh for the child
support program was enacted in 1975 so
this program has been in existence for
50 years and in the last you know 10 to
15 years the child support program has
really moved to a family centered whole
family approach and that is certainly
something that we strive for and take
great pride in here in New Hampshire as
at the bureau as well so in your slide
deck we I have U put references to all
of our governing authorities for you
should you wish to um uh reflect on
those and act as
resources um of course as I mentioned
one of our key um areas of program
operations is to uh help engage families
to comply with their support orders and
in doing so we can offer uh we have kind
of a broad array of different types of
authority to be able to help families
comply with their orders when they are
unwilling and it's important to note
that their ability to pay must be taken
into consideration when we're looking at
um uh taking that Authority um towards
uh helping families to comply but our
first line of defense is always to
really look at what the economic
barriers are to fam's success to be able
to comply with those orders and try to
alleviate those barriers as much as
possible by connecting them with
Community Resources and services however
possible so
again um we have provided a little bit
of our um information about what those
um authorities are for you if you have
any specific questions we'd be happy to
try to answer them you know really we
contribute to the strength and economic
mobility of families by collecting and
dispersing child support that is owed to
them and we work with a number of
additional departments um excuse me
additional members of our departments to
help facilitate hate that what I just
would like to um convey in closing is
that you know we really are more than
just a collection agency or an
enforcement agency we do help to uh um
provide uh you know alleviate stressors
for families help connect them to
communities establish paternity bring
parents together um ensure that they
engage with positive um and healthy
interactions whenever possible and uh
work to again service the whole family
uh as much as we can so we are here to
assist you however we possibly can as
you move forward with your session uh if
there are any uh specific questions
regarding child support or the program
that we would be happy to answer to you
um and we thank you for your time uh
Madam bureo chief on page eight the top
slide one of the enforcement remedies is
listed as passport denial we have a bill
coming before us this afternoon an
individual the way his paycheck and
transmitt thing broke
goofily he was 4 cents short but
therefore the only reporting was he was
not in compliance so his passport was
denied so this afternoon we want to keep
passport denial for the dead beats but
we do not want to have someone like
himself as he has and people like him
that he knows so that'll be coming up
this afternoon also to your knowledge or
actually anybody else's knowledge we
looked at the question of license
suspension in the last legislative
session because it's very hard to Garner
somebody's wages if they can't drive to
their job and they live in a place where
there is you know we don't have a subway
system in New Hampshire um so I don't
know what did we do with that last term
does anybody remember representative
Raymond both of those
um there were issues with whether or not
we would lose I think it was like $20
million a year in federal funding if we
passed those bills okay so I'll be
interested to hear what the updated
numbers are for how much Federal funding
is tied to those Federal requirements
that child support comply with thank you
so much um in our hearings from the
general public and the special committee
on Family Court um we had numbers of
people testify that the
spouse was under a Judicial income
withholding order but the income wasn't
withheld and that there were people who
could pay but didn't pay and one person
says that is either fantasy or an
outlier but we kept hearing that and
this isn't to put anybody Judiciary or
yourselves on the spot it's just um
should someone come to me with that
complaint about the spouse that that
person is not observant of the court
to so I if if an in if a family
structure has a order for child support
and the court has ordered that that um
child support be paid by an in
assignment either parent can apply for
our services and we can assist them with
initiating an income withholding order
thank you so much any other questions
from anyone else on the
committee seeing none thank you bureau
chief counselor or did you have a
presentation counselor I do not Mr
chairman thank you very much and my
information on there's as on there's oh
is your mic
on it is I guess it is now a little red
light appears yeah um so what what is
the threshold for
considering um passport refusal in aares
what I mean 4 cents seems ridiculous to
me
um what is there a threshold before you
go because I'm going to be straight up
I'm still oldow 70 ,000 in child support
right so I could understand you holding
his passport and everything else if you
could ever find him but 4 cents just
seems really ridiculous to me and how
happen oh thank you for the thank you
for the question representative um and
we can expand on that later on this
afternoon and but I think I I would say
that preliminarily
talking about passport or passport
program it's a federal program and they
set the guideline to be
$2,500 so if if someone is in $2500 in a
then they get submitted to the passport
denial program
um it will stay denied until it reaches
zero or if they work
out something with our agency so if they
theoretically U and I can't speak speak
about this person's case or do I really
know anything about this particular case
but
hypothetically um what should happen is
a person would get notification from
Department of State I believe um I can
verify that but they would get
notification that their passport was
denied and they would be most likely
prompted to reach out to their case
officer with a bureau and the idea is to
sort of work out something that's going
to be agreeable to the all parties and
so you know or if there's a hardship for
example um those types of factors can be
taken into consideration as well I'm I'm
hoping Council you can be here for that
hearing which is at 2 o'clock I will be
Mr chairman thank you any other
uh
oh good morning Mr chairman good morning
everyone my name is Marie Nunan and I'm
the director for the division for
children youth and families and I was
appointed to my role um in September of
20124 however I've worked for DCF for
the past 25 years in various capacities
so I'm happy to be here this morning to
present to you and I'm happy to answer
any questions that you have today or as
good morning Mr chairman good morning
members of of this very very important
committee my name is Susan laraby and I
am chief of legal Regulatory and
legislative affairs or you can just call
me Susan um and I have been with the
division for children youth and families
for exactly a year uh it's been a year
on Friday before that I was a career
prosecutor here in maram County as well
as in Brooklyn New York and neither one
of you come from New Jersey the string
is broken I'm that's right remember Jeff
and Joe yeah okay that's right excuse me
I to interrupt Mr chair but some see
okay it's still coming around the
handouts they're coming this way that's
you does everyone have a copy of the
presentation coming uh do you have a
copy of the presentation yes okay yes
you so this morning I I will present you
an overview of dcyf including our
mission some data and um information
about our strategic priorities and
looking forward in the future and I'll
start on slide one with our dcyf mission
and our mission is to really partner
with families and communities to provide
resources and supports that lead to the
safety and healthy development of
children youth and the communities in
which they live and I do want want to
emphasize the work that dcyf does on
behalf of children and and youth with
their families uh many people that um
think about the work of dcyf and
sometimes even the workforce um as we
interview um potential new hires think
about the work that we do with children
but the Partnerships that we have with
families are really important to ensure
that families have what they need to be
children there are three primary
functions of DCF
and those are Child Protective Services
Juvenile Justice
Services and the work at the senuna
Youth Services
Center for Child Protective Services we
operate under RSA
169c and within that RSA we investigate
and assess allegations of child abuse
and neglect and we provide for the
safety permanency and well-being of
child victims or children at risk of
maltreatment under our juvenile Justice
Services we have delinquency which is
under 169b and chins or child in need of
services which is under RSA 169
D and within our Juvenile Justice
Services we also support Children and
Youth and we seek to remediate the
challenges with delinquency and also
support Children and Youth identified as
children in need of
services the cun you Services Center is
within RSA
621 and that is our secure treatment
facility and where we provide a safe and
secure environment for detained and
committed youth to receive Crisis
Intervention mental health and treatment
setting moving on to slides four and
five you'll see data reg regarding our
CH our Central intake which is the
hotline where people report concerns for
abuse and
neglect and you can see some data here
um if you look to to slide four um I'm
sorry Slide Five you'll you'll see a
better visual of the of the trend of
2023 you'll also see a breakdown um by
type of report so you'll see um at the
bottom of Slide Five the pink color is
those calls to intake that are screened
in screened in means calls that met
criteria to be investigated by our field
facing child protective service
workers the blue color are those calls
that are screened out so for a screened
out call to Central intake what that
means is it did not meet criteria for
investigation however we're still able
to provide an intervention for the
person reporting or for the family
through referrals that we make from
Central intake or through a community
Navigator program where we have a person
with lived experience be able to make
Outreach to the reporter or the family
to again provide information and
potential
referrals the calls designated in that
yellow category are noted as additional
information so those calls to Central
intake are kept um and and sent on for
information because we're already
involved with a family so the call
itself does not meet criteria for a new
investigation however because we may
already have an open investigation or an
open case the information received is
passed on to the ongoing child
protective worker as information for
consider on side slide six these are our
total new
investigations so once a call comes
through our hotline is screened as
meeting criteria for investigation this
is the count of the total new
assessments or investigations conducted
you can see there was a dip in 2020
around the time of covid and a bit of a
steady increase from then I know I don't
have 2024 data on this slide um however
preliminarily um the number does dip
down a bit again so the trend does not
2021 slide seven shows the open cases
once a decision is made on the
investigation that it's necessary for
dcyf to open a case and serve the family
in a longer term um process of providing
services and working with the family uh
we would open a
case so the top um information the top
data slide um on slide seven shows the
trend of open cases between 2019 and
2023 and the bottom half of the slide
shows the number of children served at
any point during those
years the pink is the total number
served the blue is the number of
children served in placement or out of
Home
Care the yellow is the number of
children served in their
homes and the green are the number of
moving on to slide
eight in our Juvenile Justice we've been
under transformation since about um 2019
or a bit before that time um we began
but more significantly since 2019 and
we're really looking to build
alternatives to the Juvenile Justice
involvement through diversion and our CH
children's system of
care it's trying to understand youth
needs before they need formal system
involvement in the Juvenile Justice um
formal process where we intentionally
divert and deflect uh when the needs can
be met outside of that formal Juvenile
Justice System it's based on providing
individualized care and the rules of
Probation and case plans on identified
Youth you can see on slide nine this is
an example of one of the ways that we
would divert youth from the formal
Juvenile justice system and that's
through work with our children's system
of care um a program called Fast Forward
which is High Fidelity High F Fidelity
wraparound services and you can see
between October 16th and January of 2024
the significant increase in our use of
youth on slide 10 is a visual of our
open Juvenile Justice case
cases the top half of the slide is
numbers of Juvenile Justice case open
and you can see the decrease between
2019 and 2023 of numbers of Youth
cases the visual on the second half of
slide 10 is a count of Juvenile Justice
youth in placement and again since 2019
you can see the significant decrease in
placement slide 11 further illustrates
the work done by the juvenile justice
transformation efforts and you can see a
decrease over time in the number of
Center the greenish color is the total
number of Youth and then it's broken out
by committed and detain with committed
being the blue trend line and detained
orange slide 12 depicts deliberate work
that we're really proud of at
DCF we've made significant efforts and
will continue to for the next couple of
years to ensure that when youth or
children require out of home placement
that they're able to be um be residing
in a
community-based caregiving setting such
as kinship care or foster care rather
than um Residential Group home treatment
and on the slide on page 12 you can see
the yellow line is a depiction of the
children in kinship care and kinship um
our relatives or people known to the
child such as a coach or a babysitter or
someone um that the child is comfortable
and could live with also known as
fictive AB absolutely thank you yes so
that yellow line for the first time you
can see um in about October of 2024
crossed over so we had more children in
kinship care than we did in foster care
treatment on slide
13 there's a a brief outline here to
look at our strategic priorities for
2025 and 2026 six and we're really
looking to the Future and so what's next
for DCF so we've spent about the past 5
years really Transforming Our Juvenile
Justice System we've brought on a lot of
evidence-based um Services uh many with
with your support and so we thank you
for that um and so where do we look to
now um and this slide depicts
this so the four areas that we intend to
focus on are included in that circular
visual it's our case practice in blue
our service array in Green Building our
new YDC in Orange and in purple we'll
also be building a new electronic case
management system to replace the system
that we have currently from
1997 in our practice in the upper
leftand uh Corner we'll reduce the
percent of Youth and residential
treatment will increase the percent of
Youth who lived in family settings
kinship relative and Foster family
homes next to our service array we'll
increase children served in their own
homes and increase foster home
availability for children specifically
we hope to increase availability of for
17 our new facility will be open by
December of
2026 we'll train all employees in a
trauma informed care model called
Target and our census will not exceed 12
youth at any point in
time our case management system Granite
2026 and we believe with these goals in
mind and this Focus that we'll be able
to achieve the best outcomes possible
for the children and youth that we serve
and our goal is really to build trust
and confidence in our agencies so that
families feel um open to our involvement
open to our engagement with them open to
our ability to understand their
strengths and needs so that we can best
needs on the next slide on slide 14 I'm
just going to take a moment to dig in a
little bit further on two of the goals
practice and then the next slide will be
the service
array so under practice we're really
going to focus on ensuring that family
engagement is at the heart of
DCF we believe in proving engagement
will ensure that children can live
safely with their parents or in an
alternative setting if necessary as
often as
possible we plan to engage with families
have transparent
Communications um we want to focus on
identifying strengths and needs we also
need to ensure that caregivers so
relatives kinship providers foster care
providers feel valued feel a part of the
the the process and I feel like at the
table with us um before during and after
placement to re reduce use of
Residential Treatment by ensuring the
15 we have a dedicated focus on trying
to ensure we have the right services for
the right Children and Youth and
families at the right time we need to
strengthen our community based services
to ensure their quality and that they
are available at the time they're needed
our goal is really to prevent any child
Youth and Family from coming any more
deeply into our formal system than is
absolutely necessary to meet their needs
and how we're talking about doing that
is through engagement in these Services
is by ensuring at every opportunity so
at Central intake if we have to if we're
if we're able to stop the family from
coming into having an open investigation
by providing referrals at that Point by
re um offering a community navigator to
talk and work with the family around
their needs then we should do that and
and prevent them from having any further
involvement with DCF if we do have an
investigation let's try to service that
family with quality services through
that investigative process or through a
voluntary case if we're required to open
a case and serve the family longer term
let's make sure we can do it in the
family's home if we need to remove the
child from the home let's make sure
we're using Community Based Services uh
placement options like kinship and
foster care so our effort is really to
be as preventative in nature as possible
and again prevent the family from coming
necessary and that concludes the
presentation that I have for you today
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that you have couple things for me Madam
director on slide 13 the new facility
will that be the one that's going up in
my front yard
yes that's the one in Hamstead 200 yards
away from my house and I really
appreciate how well you folks in the
department worked to help me um let's
just say intersect with the locals of
which I'm one but still so thank you so
much for that and uh it lists here 12
youth yet we expanded it a little bit in
terms of bedrooms could you speak to why
that was absolutely thank you for that
question so we need to make sure that we
have space to spread youth out so the
new YDC will have 18 beds but the goal
will be no more than 12 youth in those
18 beds and we need the additional beds
for things like new
admissions someone that might be sick if
someone has covid we need to be able to
separate into different locations within
the building um often times there's a
court order to keep certain youth
separated from one another they might be
mutually involved in the same case we've
got um gender reasons to separate youth
so there's a variety of reasons that we
may need youth to not be congregated so
closely together so we need the
additional bed space to spread there may
be a time in the future when a committee
akin to my special committee for the
Family Division of circuit court is
convened to look at
DCF I sincerely hope we get it right
this time agreed and we I will do
everything I can to make sure if it's
reconstituted it is reconstituted in a
collaborative attitude thank you you're
welcome any other questions
representative Raymond yay thank you
very much Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question on slide number 11 um
you've broken down um kids who are
committed versus detained and I wondered
if you could explain a little bit about
what the differences are between uh
sure sure committed youth are those that
have committed an offense before age 18
where if they had been adult it would be
a felony or a
misdemeanor and detained youth are they
are not yet adjudicated and they are
ordered into the care of a restricted
facility so not a residential treatment
facility or a foster home but into the
secure
setting so just to thank you just to
clarify so the the committed um kids are
ones who have already gone to trial and
been convicted whereas detained their
awaiting
trial yes generally speaking or awaiting
a verdict yeah okay thank you other
questions representative
McMahon thank you
Mr and thank thank you for taking the
question M well team members right here
uh specific to page
five and asking what your guidance would
be relative to the screen in and screen
out Are there specific
criteria for the individuals doing these
evaluations for those who are then
determined which door they go through
next or uh is it interpretive or is it
specific on what the rules are so we
have spefic specific policy that guides
our Central intake staff so we have
child protective service workers that
take the initial calls they enter
information into our database they
review our policy and our definitions
they review any involvement that the
family already has with with us they
think about uh factors such as the age
of the child um the potential risk as a
result of any unique factors is is a
disa child is it a young infant um and
then they understand the caregivers uh
Behavior or what whatever the
allegations of abuse neglect are and
they look at that in our the lens of our
policy to make a screening decision
that's also then reviewed by the
supervisor at Central intake before the
final
decision thank you m representative
you good get the hang of it um specific
to page
seven um I'm wondering why the explosion
in the green for the in prevention
cases um for the last 20 22 and 2023
yeah that we actually view that as
positive so those prevention cases are
not they're not open court cases those
are um situations where families
voluntarily entered into an open case
either with DCF or with um one of our
two contractors who um oversee
community- based voluntary services for
and are able to provide services in an
effort to prevent deeper involvement in
the system so the increase in prevention
cases is a positive where we see
families open and interested to um the
services that we can provide follow
followup thank you um you you would
think that you would see the other lines
go down as the green bar Rises so are we
looking at a lot of kids that are still
so I'm not sure that we would so the
those that are in green are sometimes
the highest need families that often
don't get served um through DCF or its
Community Service uh availability so
while I realize we're not seeing a
decrease in the total um children served
overall um I I still would not see it as
a negative to know that we're serving
more children um in those prevention
cases okay thank you thank you and
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here and taking my
question my question is related to slide
five and I'm wondering if you could
please um help me understand a little
bit better and I'll just give you a
scenario um that I thought about in my
mind um if there is a family that has
let's say three um um open cases uh
three different
allegations um and um there is an a
another
call
um the allegation would be unrelated to
the three that are already open would
that be regarded as a fourth open case
information so if there are three
allegations regarding a family and a
fourth unrelated is called in to our
Central intake each allegation needs to
meet our criteria um as representative
McMahon outlined and asked of me so each
unique allegation needs to meet criteria
to result in an investigation regarding
that allegation so it would be taken on
its own Merit based on the call to
us but exactly I think maybe the point
that you're asking describes what the
additional information is so so if that
fourth call did not meet the criteria
for a new physical abuse allegation
let's just say that would be sent on to
the current child protective service
worker as added information so here this
did not meet criteria but here's some
information that you could talk with a
family about may help answer a question
for you might give you the name of a
collateral person that you could contact
to learn more about but again each each
allegation in and of itself needs to
meet its own criteria or else it's an
additional information thank you y any
further question from the committee
representative
rice thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question regarding um the new
YDC facility Could you um refresh my
memory in the legislation that passed in
informing this was there a provision in
there for um reports of
monthly
census do you recall I'm sorry I don't
recall that but I could get you that
information thank you
and is your question specifically once
a yes because that's when the 12 to 18
will be there and I'd like to keep track
of the
census you'll keep us Sur praised yes
good thank you anyone
else thank you so much Madame director
counselor and just for clock management
uh we're moving on to the Judiciary at a
no later than 11:30 I think we'll be
okay you are very good with clock
management by the way you help us so
much good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Kya
Fox I am the director of the division
for Behavioral Health with me I have
Daryl Tenny who is the bureau chief for
the Bureau of uh children's Behavioral
Health and he'll be speaking to the deck
that you're just getting right now I
want to open by first saying that I had
the opportunity yesterday to spend a
little time prepping for this and I read
each of your bios um so I went online
and I was looking at the legislative and
said who's on that committee and it
really struck me how um
great depth and um experience that you
all have in this space so we're going to
talk about the children's system of care
in a formal Manner and it's actually in
statute the system of care but just
realize you are part of the system of
care and I hope you recognize that as we
talk about all the service that we do
provide for families and children and so
with that I'll describe the division um
we are made up of the division of as I
said the um the Bureau of children's
Behavioral Health we also have the
Bureau of drug and alcohol Services the
Bureau of Mental Health Services which
addresses the adult
population and the Bureau of homeless
services is and all together we work um
side by side to really address the needs
of families when it comes to behavioral
health
conditions and again um going back to
the system of care in statute it is to
have an integrated and comprehensive
delivery structure for the provision of
publicly funded Behavioral Health
Services to New Hampshire Children and
Youth and so again we're going to be um
talking about a lot of things that we
know and they come off the tip of our
tongue very easily and it may not be as
familiar to you so please understand
when we talk um about these if you want
more description please just let us know
and we'll be happy to do that but the
bottom line is we're here to serve
families and children in their
behavioral health needs so with that I'm
going to turn it over to Daryl who will
walk you through the deck
thank you very much good morning chair
good morning committee uh to many of you
I'm new um it's great to meet everybody
um hoping to see you this this group
much more in the future um a lot of the
work that we do is Broad and um
understanding that this overview um goes
into a broad lens in many different ways
um I'm I'm hoping to tell a story I'm
hoping to share the picture um I'm
hoping to talk about the the children's
system of care work that's been
happening for for many
years um I you know I I do want to give
a a shout out to our small But Mighty
Bureau for children's Behavioral Health
I've been with our Bureau since 2016
I've been in a clinical role for many
years prior to that I know I I probably
look a little bit young sitting here um
I I assure you I've been in the clinical
role for uh a couple decades um so I I
understand the children's system I've
done a lot of work um with the
children's system of care as we've as
we've built it together um so I will
follow through the slides I've been
known to go off the script here and
there uh you may hear that but I welcome
any questions and and we'll we'll move
on through um I I do want to say it's
it's hard for families to navigate
systems I I think we I want to recognize
that I I've being in this field for as
long as I have I've seen it I've I've
lived it um I have children of my own um
I understand what it's like to navigate
um needs of children and um having
families uh struggle through that is
difficult uh We Serve All Families in
that way um and the children's system of
care framework is really meant as a way
to ensure that families uh are are able
to go through a Continuum of Care as
easily as possible um our our previous
presentation talked a lot about systems
and prevention of highlevel needs and as
you as I go through this uh presentation
you'll see why this is so critical to be
able to help prevent youth from high
levels of care to meet those needs and
so we have we have children all over our
communities um with behavioral health
challenges we need we looking to build
resilience is really important if you
turn to slide three um you're going to
you're going to see a lot of pre-work
that has been done to help support the
work that we've done over the last uh
handful of years at least um one of
which Kya had mentioned already RSA 135f
which is our system of care uh law and
so um I know Kya had shared uh the the
information around that law but it's
been critical um and really required us
to to have in Statue a Continuum of Care
for all children what you're going to
see for the next several slides are uh
the the tiered Services the tiered
supports that we have developed or that
we collaborative collaborate very
closely with with other parts of the
department other partners in our local
communities um but I wanted to at least
ensure that folks here in the community
had an understanding of all of the work
that has been over over a long period of
time and I do want to highlight uh you
know this this overview will also um
Talk quite a bit around our Partnerships
as we map on
through so I'm going to shift the slide
for a bit and this is really our
children's system of care framework as
you'll see it here very colorful uh I'm
going to go through each tier uh at a
high level um but really what we what I
want to share the most from this
particular slide um is is really the
framework overall and it is truly meant
to be the Continuum right so we want
families to be able to access the level
of care that is needed when they need it
how they need it um and and that's
really important so having assessment at
each part of uh the the tiered system is
is key you'll also he uh see here that
the Valu that are um embedded in each
one of our contracts and each each one
of these tiers is really critical in in
what we do um at a bureau level at a
department level and and so I'll list
them here but um you know they're
they're all very critical we have trauma
informed family and youth driven um
Community Based ensuring youth are being
served and supported in our communities
and and culturally and linguistically
competent and again we we we ensure that
this these values are are embedded in
all of the contracts um that we oversee
at at the Children's
Bureau so I'm going to I'm going to
shift to slide five um and this is
really going to dive into our tiered one
services and and so we consider tier one
um early identification screening and
and access to resources we we rely quite
a bit on partnership in this particular
tier and I'm not going to I won't read
all of the services that are bulleted
out here for timing purposes um but it's
really critical for the committee to
understand um how far reaching those
Partnerships are um we we work very
closely with public health um there's
quite several initiatives coming out of
Public Health to support population
Health um maternal Childhood Health
early interventions um certainly other
parts of the division um and and
Department that we we collectively work
with um we do have a direct contract
with a peer-to-peer youth um grief
supports and and that has been critical
in in terms of prevention for youth that
has experienced a grief a grief or a
loss um um so that preventative tier one
Services is is really critical for what
we've built in we also work very closely
with Managed Care organizations um there
are three Managed Care organizations and
we meet with them frequently to ensure
that we're talking about certain members
that may be stuck um may may need help
navigating the system in any particular
particular way um and I and I do want to
um recognize that RSA 135f really
statutorily has us working very closely
with the New Hampshire education
department and so we're We join New
Hampshire education um to ensure that
we're providing a Continuum across
across this
tier I I did also highlight the
collaboration with Early Childhood
Services longterm supports and services
early supports and services that's also
very critical for our tier one uh
interventions so I'm going to skip to
slide six um T which we really consider
tier two Community Based Services which
are available to all um many of us know
that we've had core really uh our
community mental health centers have
been core to much of the work that we've
done for for many years in New Hampshire
um we have 10 Community Mental Health
Centers of course that provide a broad
array of supports um we do oversee co-
oversee with the Bureau of Mental Health
Services a contract for for all of those
Community Mental Health
Centers and and they Pro and we continue
to provide that quality oversight um
they're they're uh really just a core
service to that tier supports multiple
families access uh the Community Mental
Health Center system we also partner
very closely with Fe federally qualified
Health Centers um and while we don't
have any direct contracts with federally
qualified Health Centers there are over
65 federally qualified health centers in
New Hampshire um I won't name them
all of course but um we do have several
that um that attend our community or our
children's Behavioral Health our
children's system of care advisory
committee um pretty regularly so to
ensure that there's connection
there I I did want to highlight here we
our partnership especially in tier 2
around youth that are involved in
special education so our connection with
school districts are critical here um
youth with 504 plans our connection with
parent information Center um as well as
the Bureau of Developmental services are
2 so I'm going to shift to slide seven
um tier three so uh we really consider
this for when youth um and or a child or
youth or their families need some more
intensive community- Based Services this
tier is really meant to to to uh capture
and support those more intensive needs
uh within the community and you'll I
know in the previous um presentation
from DCF they had referenced a fast
forward program um we also highlight
that here we we do have two Care
Management entities that provide um
three different types of services fast
forward being one of them um we also
have an early childhood wraparound
program which is very similar to the
fastforward program just a a younger
Target population as well as a an
enhanced care coordination service that
is meant to support youth transitioning
in
either it's meant to support youth that
are either transitioning into a
residential setting or out of a
residential setting in in efforts to set
them up to to be successful in the
community we also partner very closely
with organizations uh that provide
partial hospitalization programs um
several join the children's uh system of
care advisory committee as well um and
in uh through our fast forward program
we also work very closely with several
um certified uh individualized service
option providers um many of which are
similar to um providers that DCF use um
but several other intensive inhome
providers that can be available to
families through this highlevel
service so I'm going to I'm going to
turn to slide
eight I I did want to briefly highlight
um I I am recognizing I could probably
take 30 minutes for each one of these
tiers so this high level tough for me um
I I slide eight is really um
representing for when youth is are being
contemplated for residential treatment
and this is um this has been a a
critical shift in our thinking around
how do we support youth that do need
that high level of care and and again
the the goal of the system of care is to
prevent high levels of care like
episodes of residential treatment we
want Youth and families to be successful
in the community um but when all that's
fills a youth and the family have has
tried everything we we also want to make
sure that their their needs are matching
the right type of care what slide 8
represents is a is really a New
Hampshire single standardized assessment
which is really uh meant to identify the
needs of Youth that are being
contemplated for that episode of
Residential Treatment you'll see in the
diagram below and and I I'll talk a
little bit about the child adolescent
needs and strengths on the right um but
on the leth hand side you'll see a
diagram here um which is a key reform or
transformation that New Hampshire has
gone through as it pertains to uh youth
being contemplated for residential
treatment you'll you'll see here on the
bottom left that there has been an
additional added uh Community Access um
voluntary access for youth that require
an episode of residential treatment and
that that's something that had had not
been available prior uh to a lot of our
system of care work T typically when a
youth requires a high level of care like
episode of Residential Treatment they
were being funneled to DCF and or being
placed educationally for the for that
need so this additional ability to
access uh Residential Treatment uh
allows families to access that more
quickly and then in turn um really
return to the community as quickly as
possible one I could probably spend 30
minutes on on the child adolescent needs
and strengths tool um and I know know I
don't have time for that but I did want
to recognize that this is a standardized
tool that's utilized as part of the
comprehensive assessment for treatment
process um this is a tool that's
embedded in uh essentially all of the
tiers of the children's uh system of
care framework and and we could really I
could talk and and answer any questions
around the use of the cans and how
that's integrated uh in further
slides so we'll s shift to slide nine um
this is really talking a bit around when
youth are accessing episodes of
Residential Treatment um you can see
here that this uh we we really are
considering Residential Treatment as
part of the system when a youth does
need a residential episode um it is
important that um they're matched to the
right level of care and so this is
referencing that those levels of care
programs that we support um within our
Bureau um I've talked a little bit about
that un Universal assessment process
that process helps to determine the
right level of care or makes a makes a
recommendation to an appropriate level
of care and and then I talked a little
bit about the the new created Pathways
for voluntary episodes of treatment in
tier slide slide 10 really recognizes
tier five which we consider the acute
care and crisis response tier um these
are typically for youth that are
experiencing some level of crisis in in
need a quick response um this this
includes um our oversight of um the
access point um a mobile crisis response
and um many of you may know we do have a
Statewide mobile crisis response in New
Hampshire U for both adult and childrens
and so we work very closely and partner
very closely with the Bureau of mental
health services around that crisis um
mobile crisis work and that that's been
critical for the system of Care Success
over the last H few years or so
we do work we we do work very closely
with emergency Departments of course
when youth um are are staying there
being evaluated in an emergency
department perhaps for an acute
psychiatric
hospitalization um we do we do hear
about those cases pretty frequently
there are um certainly um built-in uh
meetings to talk about the you know
quote unquote youth that are stuck um
and and so we work with our emergency
departments very closely to ensure that
we can get the youth to the right level
of care and and we we also have the New
Hampshire Hospital Association joining
our advisory committee as
well and I do want to recognize um this
is really where our partnership with um
our one designated receiving facility at
Hamed Hospital sits and we we do partner
very closely with Hamed for youth um
that are receiving acute psychiatric
hospitalization wall at Hamad um whether
they're stepping down back to the
Community we want to ensure that they um
they're being referred to the right
types of services that best meets their
needs or if they're being contemplated
for that high level of care that they're
that we're already talking about that
transition plan thereafter so that
close slide 11 is is really exciting um
essentially exciting for me so I'll hold
that as bias but um it's it's our
children's Behavioral Health Resource
Center website and um good news is
everything that I'm sharing here is
really it lives in this website and it's
really meant to be a resource for
families for providers um on this
website you will find um search tool
different uh really a breakdown of the
levels of care um helping families
navigate where their needs may fit
potentially within that within the
system of care structure um there is a
living maintained uh living breathing
maintained the Search tool that is
available to All Families so that the
families can search based on the needs
of the child um and so um this went live
back in January it's I can't believe
it's already been a year but it went
live back in January of
2024 um and so we've been we've been
really um supporting um that through
contract um it is a.gov website and um
it's consistently maintained um from a
resource standpoint um I will I will
mention there's you know there's kind of
a graph traffic on the right hand side
there there's two Pathways one for
families of course one for providers um
this also allows um or really U
organizes uh key trainings for providers
um particularly around uh evidence-based
practices for for um you know for their
staff or for other folks that they may
be part of their agencies so this is
this is really exciting for us to be
able to help get Youth and families and
providers to the to the right type of
care
so I think hopefully I've done a nice
job kind of outlining um what we've done
to date um it's been a it's been a huge
lift um there continues to be um a lot
of work to be done and so when I think
we um reflect that pretty consistently
what you see in slide 12 is is um really
referencing how how do we continue to
grow um how do we continue to grow the
system of care to ensure that families
are um able to walk through the a
Continuum um without getting stuck
without um without waiting until crisis
um and to preventively support their
needs 12 really is uh or slide 12 is
really um identifying that we are
working to uh towards a system of care
assessment process we do have a uh a
contract with a vendor that is really
diving in uh into depth into making best
recommendations around next steps Where
Do We Go From Here uh critical areas
critical Focus are areas um where we can
continue to better um uh continue to
build and grow what we've been doing
across the children's system of care
work so on slide 13 that really breaks
down that system of care assessment
process um you can see here on the le-
hand side in purple um a few of the
focus areas of this assessment overall
um I do want to identify U to the rest
of the committee that um this is part of
the road map the commissioner's road map
and it's built in so we're consistently
um updating and and talking about the
the the system of care assessment and
and and how that's going we from a
timeline perspective we are um working
towards the last legs of that contract
and so we do anticipate working towards
a final report having some some key
recommendations and key themes being uh
coming out of that assessment um in the
so I will say the the last slide on 14
is is uh sort of loaded with contact
information and I know um um you know
John Williams uh shared some liaison uh
contact info this is specific for our
Bureau so you can see here I do have my
bureau chief contact at the top um I did
want to outline and and really um you
know give kudos to our a small But
Mighty Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health Team um they do a lot of work and
and they support quite a bit of these uh
children's system of care initiatives
that I've
outlined um in within the presentation
so will you take questions as we wrap it
up absolutely does anyone have a
question for bureau chief Tenny or
division director
Fox representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that overview
I think a lot of this is new to me and
I'm sure other people too um last
session one of the things that kept
coming up was the number of children
waiting for um inpatient care who were
like stuck in emergency rooms has there
been any movement over the last say year
or so on that and do you have any plans
through this that would help with that
problem yeah great question
representative thank you um yes I from
from my vantage point we've seen we've
seen uh Improvement on that number and
and why while I I'll sit there saying
it's improved our mission right we don't
want youth sitting in the emergency room
we do want youth to the right level of
care um this is something that's
consistently viewed and um we we do have
consistent meetings um where we ensure
that youth are navigating through the
system in the way that they need to um
so when there is a youth stuck in in the
emergency room awaiting an acute
psychiatric hospitalization we are
working very closely with their clinical
supports with their um with with other
agencies that may be involved with the
family to ensure that they're they're
moving um in some level I have seen
Improvement um I can I sit here and say
it's perfect probably not um but I
comparatively speaking to several years
ago there has been some vast Improvement
um and um I do anticipate that we'll
we'll have some recommendations from the
system of care assessment that I
outlined at the very end um in some of
those recommendations we'll talk pretty
pretty closely around that thank you
question thank you do we have any
further
questions thank you for your time we
really appreciate you coming I'm sure
appreciate next I'd like to invite um
Judiciary to come forward attorney Erin
cre
and uh Judith
up good morning good morning um thank
you Madame VI is it Madame Vice chair
thank you and members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
come before you today um to tell you a
little bit about and give you some an
orientation to the judicial branch an
overview of the circuit court and
specifically uh the Family Division uh
for the record my name is Judge Ellen
Christo I'm the administrative judge of
the uh New Hampshire Circuit
Court um so for excuse me your honor uh
do you have handouts oh so you have
handouts already that have been passed
out that should be in in front of you
already thank you looks like this
thank you kindly ma'am proceed my
pleasure all right for for those of you
who already are very familiar with the
uh judicial branch I apologize this may
seem uh a little high level but I I
wanted to make sure that everybody uh
had at least the 30,000 foot level view
uh of the judicial branch and of the and
then we'll get into the weeds of the
Circuit Court u in
particular so um I'll start with the
overview of the branch and then shift
specifically to the Circuit Court uh
today's presentation is intended just as
an overview and I'll be happy to work
with you on specific legislation uh as
you go through the
session so I want to start by just
mentioning our mission uh the mission of
the judicial branch our goal is to
provide accessible prompt and efficient
forums for the fair and independent
administration of justice with respect
um going to page three I want to just
talk briefly about the structure of the
judicial branch so I like to think of
our our structure as a bit of a we're
sort of a triangle uh New Hampshire has
two trial courts we have the circuit
court and the Superior Court which are
the bottom edges and um points of the
triangle and at the top is the Supreme
Court so we have two trial courts and
one appell at court uh in New Hampshire
and then as you see we also have the um
Administrative Office of the courts and
that area is the part of the judicial
branch that provides uh all of the
services to all of the courts such as
human resources accounting security
Communications um all of those things
that are the same in every Court um and
I have two uh members of the AOC here
today uh with me that I want to make
sure we introduce our general counsel
for the branch Aaron krian who many of
you are probably familiar with um and
also our uh Communications manager of
Harris who put together uh the handout
uh today and is uh absolutely
indispensable for to us um each one of
the courts uh has a uh head judge a
chief judge um chief justice McDonald uh
you may be familiar with who sits uh as
the head of the Supreme Court uh judge
Howard who is the chief of the superior
court and then myself uh as the
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court um I was appointed to this
position uh by the Supreme Court uh in
July 1 of 2024 so this is a new I'm in
my first year uh in this
position so going uh and I want before
we go to the next one I want to just
point out in terms of the two trial
courts in our state uh the circuit and
Superior uh we have different
jurisdictions so the uh Circuit Court is
primarily a court of Statute so all of
the laws and statutes that you pass um
typically are often uh most applied in
the Circuit Court the superior court is
a court of equity um and we'll get into
that in in a little bit but I want to
switch to uh page four of the handout um
I want to specifically mention our
safety and security officers um these
are the men and women uh who protect us
on a daily basis uh one of the um things
that we won't surprise you is that
there's an increased uh threat
environment uh throughout the country of
Judges who have been targeted um so both
inside cour houses and out um and so
Safety and Security is a is a very
important important part of uh of the
branch uh security is provided in a
partnership uh with the uh County
Sheriff's Department who provides
security primarily in most of the um
County buildings and a lot of those
County buildings hold both Superior and
circuit courts and then there's a number
um all right and I just want to mention
uh as an aside the Gentleman on the
right uh in the picture uh on the Safety
and Security slide is a gentleman who
just retired this past year after 20s
something years uh in the branch uh with
us and that was a second career for him
so um all right so going to slide five
um I want to start drilling down a
little bit into the Circuit Court uh we
are the largest Court in the
state um we have three divisions
uh and this was created in 2011 by the
legislature uh where they combined the
family uh probate and district courts
all into one Court uh and made those
three divisions uh under one
Court uh I often will when I'm talking
to people will refer to the Circuit
Court as the People's Court uh in New
Hampshire this is where people the
average person goes uh for things that
happen in the normal parts of their life
um could be a divorce could be um a will
U from somebody who's died in a family u
a minor criminal issue uh but this is
where literally 80 to 85% of all people
in New Hampshire who access the court
system will access the Circuit
Court um and I want to just mentioned
that a significant majority of the
people who appear in front of us are
self-represented um so that's a big
Focus uh for
us going to to uh slide six um this
shows you all of the Circuit Court
locations around the state we have 34 of
them the idea is that we are a
community-based uh court so uh
the circuit court is split up into 10
circuits uh which not surprisingly uh
follow the 10 counties that we have uh
in New Hampshire uh within each C so
you'll see under those 34 locations uh
10 probate divisions so there's one
probate division in each of the counties
and then 31 District and family uh
divisions so those are spread out uh in
more places so if you want to do
something in the probate division you've
got to go to the mo in most situations
to the county
courthouse um otherwise there are
Community cour houses based all around
the
state going to slide number seven uh I
just want to talk about the makeup of of
the Circuit Court uh right now we have
um the highest number of Judges we've
ever had uh we have 49 full-time judges
three part-time or pum judges
um four judges who are in senior active
status uh which means in essence they're
part-time they're retired but they
continue to sit as an active judge
part-time and then 16 judicial
referees um all of these uh folks
are Judges who have retired and passed
the age of 70 and as many of you I'm
sure are aware you can't be called you
can't be a judge after the age of 70
based on our New Hampshire con
institution so therefore um we will
often um appoint a retired judge who has
turned 70 as a Judicial referee so that
we can still um take advantage of their
uh wisdom and services uh the only
difference is at that point you have to
have an active judge uh co-sign their
orders uh we have approximately 400
employees uh in the branch Branch uh the
vast majority of those employees are uh
state all uh Circuit Court judges um sit
in the district at least the district
and Family Division about a third of the
judges also sit in the probate division
as well um the idea here is that we're
kind of like in if you
General Practitioners if they were
doctors so we do a little of everything
um when I was sitting full-time before I
uh took this position uh I was sitting
in Hampton and Brentwood and was sitting
in all three uh divisions of the Circuit
Court going to um slide eight to give
you a sense of the overall circuit court
filings uh the three divisions District
um as of last as of last year we uh well
so I'll start with in criminal cases we
handle all misdemeanors and violations
uh so Circuit Court judges can sentence
uh people up to a year uh in prison
otherwise it's a felony it will it goes
to Superior
Court
however um as of last year felony now
come uh initially to Circuit Court for
arraignment bail hearings and probable
cause hearings uh and if a circuit court
judge finds probable cause then those
cases get bound over to Superior
Court um District also includes all
kinds of Motor Vehicle cases Fish and
Game cases uh but also small claims and
civil cases landlord tenant and civil
stocking cases uh all are in the
district division I'm going to skip
family on here for a moment and just go
to probate uh trusts and Estates uh is a
big part of of probate but also
guardianships um of incapacitated adults
and involuntary commitments that's a
huge part of our probate uh Division and
also my very favorite part of the
probate division is adoptions um that's
the happy place for all judges uh it's
one of the few very happy things we get
to do um and also name changes um we
handle uh typical year of filing is over
100,000 cases um I think the 124,000 is
from 2023 um I'm not positive but it's
typically over 100,000 cases a year are
filed in the circuit court and just to
give you some frame of reference by
contrast about 177,000 cases a year are
Court so moving on to um slide nine this
digs a little deeper into the Family
Division uh cases so we estimate about
22,000 cases are either filed or
reopened uh in the Family Division uh
annually these matters will include
unsurprisingly divorce and parenting
petitions for those of you who aren't
familiar with that um parenting
petitions are filed in cases where the U
parents aren't married so that's the
difference between a divorce and a
parenting petition um child support
cases minor
guardianships um abuse and neglect
surrenders and adoptions reg related to
abuse and neglect um all other adoptions
are in the probate division um juvenile
delinquent or surren termination and
surrender of parental rights uh juvenile
delinquency children in need of services
so all of those areas are uh a lot of
what you've just heard from DCF and and
the Bureau of Child Support so forth a
lot of that appears in front of us in
court um and then all um and then
another large area in our family
petitions so on uh going on to slide 10
I want to just briefly uh talk talk
about the divorce process divorce and
parenting petition process because
that's one of the biggest areas of uh
the Family
Division um
so this slide sort of depicts what
everybody has to do at the very
beginning of a divorce or parenting
petition uh case so uh every person who
files one of these original petitions
meets with a case manager each one of
our cour houses has a case manager um
and that person is trained to help in
particular self-represented parties uh
to provide Legal Information in the
divorce and parenting process um they
can assist with completing paperwork um
and they can also help parties fill out
paperwork uh ahead of time for a hearing
to help them prepare and know what to
expect um there's a very fine line here
uh between giving legal advice and Legal
Information uh we can't give legal
advice to to self-represented litigants
but our case managers can help them with
process and uh Legal
Information
uh the so this is a first step for
everyone if you parent if parents if
there are excuse me if a divorce or in a
parenting case uh there's children
involved uh all of the the uh litigants
are required to take the child IMPACT
Program uh to hopefully help them
understand the impact of a divorce or of
children and then going on to uh slide
11 so this digs a little further into
the weeds here uh this is the process
for a divorce or parenting petition in
the circuit court so uh the very first
thing is a first appearance and that
first appearance is actually not in
front of a judge that's typically with a
case manager um to
help help the litigants understand uh
what the process is going to look like
and what kinds of things they need to
fill out Etc and then from there on
there's different things that can happen
the majority of cases are all sent to
mediation before or there's a temporary
hearing um the idea here is the the more
we can resolve cases before they go
through the whole uh process the better
off it is for everyone
involved um and you can sort of follow
through here there's obviously lots of
process before you get to uh a final
trial in this and I want to going on to
to uh slide 12 I want to specifically
talk about mediation and arbitration a
little bit so within the Circuit Court
we have uh we oversee the office of
mediation and arbitration that office
actually serves all three courts but 90%
of the work that they do uh serves the
Circuit
Court um and and I'm I'm not going to
talk about all the things they do but I
am going to just specifically reference
the uh things that the ADR office does
for the Family Division um so they
handle organizing mediators for all uh
divorce and parenting
mediations um which is required for most
uh families with minor children it's not
required but it's recommended for uh
those without children but most judges
will order mediation um right out of the
box um reopened divorce cases so a case
and when I say reopened case what I'm
mean is for instance a divorce case
that's been fully adjudicated it's all
final there's a parenting plan in place
um and somebody wants to uh change child
support or change the parenting plan or
uh believes somebody isn't doing
something correctly under the divorce uh
terms that is they bring the case
forward and that's that's a reopened
case uh so again often most of the time
in reopened cases we send them to
mediation
first um we also in the Family Division
have a complex family docket um some of
you may be familiar with judge uh lamir
who may have testified in front of you
before she runs the uh complex family
docket and these are tend to be complex
cases that are and multi-day trial
multi-year uh cases that involve either
complex uh legal matters or major
Financial uh
matters uh we also offer neutral case
evaluation uh that's right now being
done um almost exclusively I Believe by
some retired judges uh that has it is
often done sort of closer to when people
are getting ready to go to trial uh so
all the discovery is done theyve been
probably lots of motion practice that
kind of thing and uh at that point uh
they have a retired judge give the
litigants an idea of how they think a
judge will if they went to trial where
they would come down on this case um
that has neutral case evaluation has
been incredibly successful um I don't
have the numbers in front of me today
but I can tell you that uh it's been
very successful with settling cases um
trial
uh guardianship of uh a minor there's
mediation available and there's also um
voluntary mediated agreements uh in the
termination of parental rights
area uh we do well over uh 2,000
Division switching to uh slide 13 I just
want to briefly mention uh one of our
initiatives it's the family treatment
courts uh we started a pilot program in
Newport uh in suan County last year this
is now it's not considered a pilot
program anymore it's expanded now it's a
regular program and we've expanded it
this year to um the Manchester Circuit
Court well not in full yet but uh a
piece of it and that will grow hopefully
over time as we have more resources uh
what the family treatment courts uh
purpose is is to
identify um parents who have been
um petitioned for abuse and neglect and
there's a substance abuse
problem
and the idea
being the goal is to reunify the family
and one of the things that and we have
found and this is there's great evidence
uh of this throughout the country that
these types of courts are more
successful in reunification in the long
term and what they do is it's it's a
very
intensive um
um way to wrap around all services for
uh a family both for treatment but also
finding housing finding Child Care um
and there's regular check-ins with the
court system in which all of the
providers come in um and at the same
time and it's I've had the opportunity
to go out and and and watch this in
practice in Newport and it's uh it's
quite amazing uh and it's been very
successful and uh the idea obviously is
both reunification but also uh
to uh lower recidivism rates and and to
help the actually change the whole
structure of this family's life um it is
not always successful and quite frankly
it is heartbreaking when it's not um but
it when it is uh more successful than
successful so going on to um and I was
going to encourage you that there's a
little doesn't guess really show it here
but uh if you go on our website um
there's a wonderful video uh that
features judge swier uh who's been kind
of the leader in the Family Court
treatment program in our state um that
tells you more about the program and and
gives you um a a wonderful overview of
it so I encourage you if you have the
opportunity to go on the Court's website
uh and and look at that
video uh going on to to slide
14 I want to just
briefly mention a couple of our um I'm
not going to go through each one but
just briefly mention a couple of the
accomplishments of the circuit court and
the Family Division in particular in
2024 um we've spent a lot of the end of
the year um working on implementing new
legislation that uh the legislature has
passed this past year um it involves a
lot of training for judges a lot of
training for staff members and also
changing forms there a tremendous amount
of changing forms uh when the when the
Law changes
or so uh We've ALS we've put up on our
website uh this past year some child
support and parenting plan videos uh
videos seem to be the way that a lot of
people um are gaining information lately
so uh we're trying to be responsive to
that and so instead of just having
written things on the Court's website to
follow uh we're trying more and more to
uh put up videos for people to watch and
listen to about how to how to uh access
the court and what's expected of them um
along the same lines we've uh on our
first appearance video that's where
you've filed a parenting plan or a
divorce uh We've switched that from a uh
URL code which is kind of a live link to
a QR code um again finding that uh
people can access that
easier uh We've increased uh mediator
pay uh this has been one of of a
consistent problem I think for probably
lots of both uh you know folks in the
Executive Branch the judicial branch uh
businesses in the state finding uh
employees and and people to do work uh
in certain areas we struggle to uh have
enough lawyers in the state to uh
represent families in in cases that have
mandatory uh appointments by the court
such as uh termination of parental
rights or abuse and neglect cases where
we have to uh appoint an attorney for
Mom and an attorney for Dad and now with
legislation also an attorney for the
child in certain
circumstances um so one of the keys to
this is specifically for mediators we
raise the mediator pay from $60 to $90
an hour uh to get mediators willing to
do the work um as well as of as of
January 1 this year we've also increased
the pay for Guardian ad
items um
we are doing a significant amount of new
lawyer and new judge training in the
family
area so uh folks from from the Circuit
Court provide training to the new lawyer
orientation programs uh in the for the
Family Division and then uh for new
judges we provide approximately uh two
weeks of initial training in the uh
Family Division areas as well as um on
top that shadowing of other judges and
continuing uh education uh for judges
we've had 13 new judges appointed uh in
2024 and five appointed in 2023 so we
have a huge stable of newer uh judges
and uh we are trying to provide a lot of
support uh and training to those
judges um I want to specifically mention
our text reminder uh program we've we've
uh started that as a pilot for Family
Mediation cases um it has been
incredibly successful it's very similar
to when you get a uh text from your
doctor or dentist reminding you to you
know you have an appointment the next
day um we are now piloting that uh in
the Circuit Court uh we started with a
the Family Mediation program and found
that it decreased the failure to appear
rates by 40% which was huge
um we are now piloting that in the
Criminal Division uh or the district
division specifically the criminal cases
uh in Dover and Rochester right now uh
with we don't have numbers yet because
it just started in October but um
anecdotally is doing very very well so
we might be expanding that throughout uh
the the system if we
can
um we are starting a um Guardian ad
light and pilot program for families of
lower income where there's a fund for
that now uh there are four locations
that have been uh identified and that
will launch uh shortly
and we are also uh starting this year uh
we've been putting it into place in 2024
and it'll be uh launching this year a
pre-filing uh mediation uh project plan
uh four cases in the Family Division
where you can actually get um so if you
intend to file for divorce but you and
it is perhaps amicable in a perfect
world uh that you can actually get
mediation pre-filing so that you can
work something out and potentially file
um and agreed upon uh divorce and
parenting agreements so all a judge has
to do is review it uh make sure it meets
all of the legal standards and then
consign it so that that's happening this
year as well so I am uh very happy to
answer uh any questions for you with the
caveat that obviously I can't answer any
questions regarding any specific cases
thank
you thank you um representative rice
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
mediation who pays for that
um it depends so in uh a divorce case uh
the litigants typically pay for that and
and except for this pilot program that
we're about to launch where if you are
under a certain income level you may
qualify for mediation to be paid for for
you um there are different things
throughout uh the branch where there are
some Grant there's grant funding in
specific areas
that have mediation that's paid for in
don't followup so you said that there's
going to be a new program to help
because that was my concern was the
families that can't afford to pay for
mediation um do they still get mediation
yeah so um that is a a new pilot program
and there is uh it's starting I I want
to say in four locations and then uh the
hope is to expand it beyond that perfect
you representative Greg thank you Madame
Vice chair and thank you for being here
and explaining all that and taking my
question today so in a lot of States
they have separate family courts because
the family Dynamics are so complicated
and stuff and and without that here I'm
specifically interested because one of
our most complicated parts of the family
courts is domestic violence what kind of
training uh do the judges have and is it
ongoing on domestic violence and those
complications yes representative uh it
is ongo so we let step back as a new
judge you get at least three days
dedicated in our judge training
specifically to domestic violence
um that's where we
start uh does not end there um within
the first two years of being a judge um
typically
depending on how many new judges we have
um we either uh a judge will either go
to the judicial College in Reno Nevada
for a week uh where it is it's
specifically for family but heavily um
on the domestic violence side of things
um so we get more training out there
within the first two years um
occasionally and this year is probably
going to be one of those years uh since
we had 13 new judges
uh that came on the bench uh in 2024 we
will likely bring the trainers to New
Hampshire as opposed to sending the
judges uh to Nevada um because it's just
more cost efficient uh to do that and
train all of and they'll have a two to
three day intensive training uh at at
that probably later this year um in
addition um we have ongoing training uh
periodically throughout throughout the
entire Branch but also specifically uh
in the in the Circuit Court um I will
share with you that I am the uh chair of
the internal standing uh domestic
violence committee within the judicial
branch uh so it is something that I am
very much on top of uh and that we uh in
addition to formal training on it for
judges we also have what we call the
list serve uh where it it's in essence
sort of an ma uh bank for judges that
when we have questions not maybe being
not being sure what to do or not wanting
to recreate the wheel or has another
judge encountered these types of facts
things like that that we can share
information uh with each other and that
is used uh quite a bit and uh DV cases
are something that that comes up uh on
that frequently um and uh in addition to
that uh we meet on our regular basis
with the um domestic violence coalition
to get people's concerns um and are
constantly working on trying to make
that area better so we can serve the
citizens of New Hampshire are in the
that representative
love thank you madam chair and thank you
your honor for coming in giving us all
this information today uh my pleasure
first of all I want to commend the the
court system for the family treatment
courts um much of the family's problems
are generational you I don't have to
tell you that uh alcoholism and drug
addiction uh is running rampant and and
ruining the lives of kids and uh you
know if if you save one in 10 uh you
know it's a major a major gain and uh
the question I do have is
um would it be your office that uh that
people could register complaints with
about uh uh judicial and court officer
Behavior so sort of
I would say we do have um we have an
email and so yes to start with we do
have an email um and people write
letters and and use the email system um
if they have a complaint uh it's
a blanking on off the top of my have but
it's a
at. yeah so it's a court con Court
concerns at and uh Aon will give
everybody the uh the
full eail if if you'd like to have it um
so that is one place that you can do
that
conduct the the letter that the con that
your constituent might get back on
something like that um is likely to go
to the judicial conduct committee with
it um so it is so
if there are specific things like um you
know that that perhaps somebody was rude
at the counter of staff that definitely
should come to my office
um we get a little of everything um we
we read and look at every complaint that
comes in um some of the things
are frankly people who might be
disgruntled because they lost their case
or
they feel like they lost their case and
so they're not happy about it um and a
lot of you know there are times people
don't feel like they were treated fairly
uh because of that
uh so there's also the appeal process so
if people aren't happy with the outcome
of their case that's really not a a
complaint to my office that's an appeal
to the Supreme Court um so that's why I
said sort of to begin with yep
repes representative
georgees thank you Madame chair um I'm
very excited when I saw the when talk
about the case management and uh I would
like you to know about the case
management is it new in system or if
it's nothing new when that start yeah
it's it's not new um I think it has
evolved over time um and I don't know
exactly when frankly you know this my
first year in in this position so I
don't know exactly when it went into
place but um but it's not new uh and I'd
say several years ago there was at least
a a movement to make sure there was a
case manager in each courthouse uh to
work with it's kind of one of those
things I think it's um not as well known
and perhaps
underutilized by uh litigants who come
to court so I think maybe that's a a job
for us to do is to make sure that that
uh is easier or more well
known thank you very much but I think so
it's really it's better to for the
people to know because I know um a lot
of people in the community suffer about
you representative
Nelson thank you Madame Vice chair and
thank you for taking my request um May I
please have an additional copy of this
presentation to give to our committee
assistant for our file absolutely thank
you well we have one yes absolutely
thank
you
right seeing no further hands raised
thank you very much for your time your
honor thank you it's my
privilege
you
uh attorney eron
KGAN we're going to give you about five
minutes because we've run over it's that
enough I will go for 30 seconds if I
can um we love you more and more every
second I I I don't know whether to say
good afternoon or good morning it might
be right on the edge uh but hello
everyone Aon crean general counsel for
the judicial branch I just want to
introduce myself for any new members and
um if you don't have a card I'm going to
try to put one in your hand before you
go um I know that getting in touch with
folks from the courts can be a challenge
they're in court you know they're not
necessarily as available as um the folks
on the contact sheet for for DHHS my
intention is to be available and
accountable to you call me email me text
me I will get back to you especially if
you need something right away I will get
the information from the right person or
I will get you in touch with the right
person uh please do not hesitate to
reach out to me for anything you need so
I just wanted to introduce myself and
make myself available and accountable to
you as you're starting out your new
year thank you very much we look forward
to working with you thank you madam Vice
you and with that we're going to close
the morning's events uh we're going to
uh go to
lunch um we need to be back here I I
would ask you to come back by five
minutes to one so that we can get
settled in and begin our first hearing I
appreciate all your attention do we have
lunch
e
it is now 1:00 and the chair opens the
hearing on House Bill 170 and calls upon
representative Michael Moffett to
thank you Mr chair starting right on
time very impressive uh chairman Co Mr
chairman yes I sit on the chair yes
Kudos and plotts for that appreciate it
uh for the record uh I'm representive
Mike Moffett of maram County District 4
which includes the beautiful towns of
Canterbury and Lowden and I am HB 170s
Prime sponsor
so I get involved with this uh when
representative the representative from
Northampton contacted me last year after
he'd been approached by some folks uh
from his district uh from whom you'll
hear later concerning possible needed
legislative actions with regard to
military
pay uh I again for the record I'm a
retired uh US Marine uh Reserve officer
and I and I also chair the house
veterans
committee so an issue here is disposable
military retirement pay uh as opposed to
pensions and the distinction between
retirement pay and pensions is important
later these folks hold that retired pay
should not be considered a tangible
asset or as property in the legal sense
when it comes to divorce settlements I
think they have a point and that maybe
is the perhaps the most Salient
important aspect to which you're going
to be looking at here with this bill is
the notion that retirement pay is not
property uh you'll note the measure
includes a a very small change to RSA
458 colon 16a in that it crosses out one
line that refers to military retirement
and veterans disability benefits and it
replaces it with a single sentence
stating quote property shall not include
disposable retired pay as defined by us
code 10 section 1408 unquote
so should military retirement pay be
considered property in divorce
proceedings involving veteran assets
that again as I just said that's the nub
of it now should this move forward the
new statute language would give New
Hampshire officials and judges more
discretion to structure fairer more just
civil settlements for military people in
divorce situations in accordance with
Federal code in with New Hampshire law
uh this is a little bit like the
veterans court measure I sponsored last
year which is now and what that did
Judge or the uh representative from
window judge Lenn uh was a was a uh
co-sponsor of that measure and the
veterans court measure um gave judges
more freedom and sentencing discretion
so they would have more options to do uh
types of separate uh sentencing from
veterans short of
incarceration so that is a sort of a
precedent for what the intent is here is
to give our courts to give our judges uh
more statutory grounds for discretion
and flexibility and choice when it comes
to making decisions in civil divorce
cases and again not everyone understands
that military retirees remain at their
nation's call okay just because
someone's retired from the military
doesn't mean that they're they're done
in fact uh there are nor actually
numerous cases of retirees getting
retirement pay uh being called back to
work back to active duty in fact I
myself helped to activate two retirees
and return them to Temporary active duty
when I commanded a military school in
San Diego so that is relevant as well
okay retirement pay we do not see that
as a is a as a product
okay we see retirement pay is something
that is not fully understood or handled
in the best way so anyway the uh the
following speakers will drill down and
get into details with regard to HB 170
it and its implications I'm sure they
will welcome questions uh normally I
would invite questions but I I need to
cross the hall um over to education
committee where the the scheduling gods
have me introducing another 1 pm Bill uh
you should already have some pink cards
from from some star Witnesses so uh I
think this is a very the more I find out
about this area of law uh the more
interesting it is and the more I'm
convinced that uh some attention needs
to be paid to the situation and some
awareness
raised so if the chair will grant me a
temporary leave of absence I will egress
from this area of operations for for
another will you be able to come back
after you've introduced your bill across
the hall and I asked that because uh in
conversation with a few members there
are some uh pretty particular questions
or do you have somebody designated who
can answer those questions for you thank
you for that uh Mr chairman um I I am
going to be immersed across the hall for
probably 45 minutes and I know there's
certain timelines I'll come back if I
can but I the co-sponsor will follow me
and he uh and the other speakers are
experts Duty experts on this and I'll
come back if I can and if I can't uh I'm
very confident that the folks following
me can can give you good answers who is
that person you wish to come up next uh
I would like to see the uh co-sponsor by
the way it's a bipartisan measure the
representative from Northampton is uh he
is in the house I have a visual on I
believe he goes by
m uh that
sounds that sounds Italian like thises
the the representative from Milford
could maybe confirm confirm the uh okay
you can go now thank you thank you Mr
chairman recognizes representative Jim
maor is that was that right did I get
that well those two years of your
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for the record
my name is Jim
maor and I represent the beautiful
Seaside community of Northampton and
very proud to be a co-sponsor of this
bill I'll speak briefly because the
gentlemen behind me are subject experts
and can certainly answer your questions
uh when Mr cin brought this bill to me
several years ago uh he raised a
question to me well the bill the subject
matter raised a question which I
reiterated to him just a little while
ago in the cafeteria and that is this
the magic that happens with I guess the
IRS or the courts where money turns from
property into into property and seems to
morph back with no real concrete
evidence of how that happens or how it
is established and that is the Crux of
this bill to to set into
stone where Equity where to set into
stone the policy by which Equity can be
reached in in this issue so with that Mr
chairman I I'm very grateful to the
prime sponsor representative Moffett I
reached out to him as the very first
person because I know he's a veteran and
I'm very grateful for his service I
thought he would know more and I'm I'm
very grateful that this is not only a
bipartisan bill but I feel a nonpartisan
issue because we are just trying to find
something that works for the residents
of north of excuse me of New Hampshire
and with that I will take any questions
but we'll probably defer all of them to
the gentlemen behind me just a reminder
to the committee especially the first
termers that you speak briefly and you
ask a question with that in mind any
majori representative
rice thank you Mr chairman can you
please explain to me the term
disposable retired
pay thank you representative for the
question I would love to but the but the
best most comprehensive answer will come
from the gentleman behind me I I they
will they are better prepared to answer
the question sure well with that in mind
could I then defer to the gentleman
behind you thank you so much thank you
and uh again for freshmen especially it
is the house custom that when
Representatives have filled out a pink
card they go near the top because they
have other pressing duties in the house
jurus and every time I hear about the
thank you Mr chairman thank you I I do
miss it uh uh except maybe on days that
are around Z degrees and the trains
don't uh don't like to get out of the
out of the yard on on days like or
mornings like today but uh uh Lou jerus
here State Rep from uh Ward s in Nashua
thank you for having me here right
looking at the HB 170 I think it's um
it's it's a start and rethinking
thinking the retirement benefit division
in in matters of divorce uh with you
know with the idea
of creating some more parity or at least
relieving some of the burden for life
from the actual from the pensioner um in
the case of military pensions like in
all pensions uh in New Hampshire the
receiving you know spouse is entitled to
after a long-term marriage entitled to
50% um that would be the marital portion
as as you know defined by the
by the Hoskins rule if it's less than
50% they would run that formula through
and and and to determine the amount of
uh of the monthly amount um uh unlike
real property or unlike a checking
account or uh other retirement like 401k
or
457b you don't just the deal just isn't
done and you move on this is a monthly
thing that that goes on in
perpetuity um once the quadr was done
and uh you uh are ready to sell either a
home or ready to separate a checking
accounts or savings accounts um those
things end but this you know the monthly
payments come every month and uh you
know after a while this this could
create imbalances with especially the
pensioner but also maybe even the person
receiving former spouse receiving the
pension um so there is no end dat and um
unlike alimony or unlike child support
there's a means test um you know it's
it's you you rule according to the rule
125a you give you about your assets you
you give how much you make what your
burdens are financially and they come up
with a formula and in and in cases of
alimony it's it's usually a negotiated
thing the the the one of the spouses is
going to need some money for a
particular period of time and that
sunsets after uh after 10 years
um uh you know on so on the flip side of
this too um we have to be careful I mean
it it would be good to have a statute
that maybe like was said earlier that
judges could uh take have more leeway in
where uh the receiving spouse if they
were in the home they were taking care
of the children uh do doing various
other functions um would should have a a
decent uh probably be considered for a
good amount of that that pension uh or
or somewhere uh that approach is half um
it all should be considered if that
spouse who is who wasn't in the military
or anywhere else if they have a pension
to and what their retirement benefits
are um so having that kind of U uh say
in in how these things are are portioned
out how the pensions are portioned out
is is important um uh so you you know
the 50% AF for a long-term marriage can
again should be looked at I think this
this HB 170 is is a good first step so
keep in mind too that everything a lot
of these m a lot of the assets and um
whether they're tangible or intangible
you can negotiate these things if the
parties or one of the parties or both
parties are willing to negotiate in some
cases
where the law is on the side of the
person who has less
assets and the statute says 50% of let's
say in this 50% of the pension there's
no
real compelling reason to negotiate when
you know if you go forward in court
you're probably going to get the 50% of
the of the pension and that's the reason
for maybe having a statute that either
takes the pension off the table or at
least there's more there's allow there's
more leeway allowed again you can you
can take less child support you can take
less alimony than you're entitled to you
can take less than half the portion of
your house if people are willing to
negotiate you make a settlement and just
bring it forward to the court and it's
done but there are cases where it's not
it's contentious and um I I can see why
in in a scenario with a pension it would
it would go the it would go far in the
process um keep in mind too that you
know you can get your representation a
lot of times attorneys in these law
firms will ad ized that they uh they're
good at extracting assets and good at
extracting especially pensions to some
law firms it seems like the Crown Jewel
that you know if you come with me I'll
be able to get as much of your uh I'll
be able to get as much of this pension
for you as possible etc etc uh and that
I I you see that uh when it comes down
to these mediation and some of these
attorneys who are in family law as well
uh and you got to be careful not to get
hustled either while trying to make a
need to wrap it up now Y and uh with
that any questions do we have questions
representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
sure um are you aware of how other
states handle this situation and all the
testimony I've heard so far from from
what I'm able to see it's pretty similar
from what I understand I'm I'm not an
expert but I from what I understand it's
pretty similar they
just it's just half and there's no
there's no income test if you will uh it
doesn't consider other assets or what
you make later in life whether you re
you maybe you remarry you live with
somebody else and you're getting two
grand a year on top of your $80,000
salary and anyway you know the scenarios
are are you know they are what they are
uh other questions anyone else with a
question representative Raymond thank
you um so I'm confused about the intent
of the language change because um and so
maybe you can clarify it for me because
back if we go back to the 70s military
pensions were not considered assets and
so they weren't part of a divorce
process so a parent who had been staying
home taking care of the kids while the
spouse was in the military got zero
dollars of the pension then in
1982 the um us former spouses protection
Act was passed which allowed States to
consider the pensions in the divorce
decree but it doesn't require a specific
amount so if we change this language
will this language change still give
judges the discretion to do 10% or 5% or
whatever depending on the length of the
marriage and the amount of time that the
other spouse was out of the workforce or
would this go back to the 70s where the
spouse gets nothing because the way I
read the language is it does not include
would mean that the judge couldn't order
any of
it the best I can give is that's how it
looks I I'm not familiar with the the
structuring of the bill okay that's what
it and again if earlier when I mentioned
giving the court leeway to make
adjustments for exactly what your
question just said for a spouse who was
in the home and was uh taking care of
basic taking care of business in the
family right okay while the deployments
and whatever and work was happening in
the military yeah um do you want a
follow up no I I think my followup is
just I think that this language just the
opp no testifying um anyone
else representative
rice thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I too am concerned
about the language um shall not is shall
not um so again can can you explain to
me disposable retired
pay the way I read it it's what's what
the amount is in Gross after the um
Hoskins rule was determined by the
financial um expert usually it's
somebody who deals with the representing
attorney thank you yeah that's probably
what it is and then of course you do the
quadro to have that you know dispersed
still representative
Grossman okay well you will promis me me
a name change at one point eventually
okay we'll do it we'll work on that
representative Grossman thank you uh
chairman Pearson um thank you
representative for coming before us so
I'm just trying to
clarify are we taking out I think this
Raymond writes
for one of the spouses to have access to
the military retirement benefits so are
we taking that off the table during a a
mediate like stop short of going to
mediation are the military retirement
benefits according to this house bill
170 no longer on the table in terms of a
divorce negotiation for the spouse it
reads what it reads again didn't craft
the or I didn't craft the the measure um
but it as far as I know you can
negotiate you can negotiate what you
know what you can negotiate so and as
long as the court
agrees they can go forward follow up the
follow but that was the intent of this
bill
correct I could be it could be again I'm
testifying for leeway for for you know
for for
rethinking the
way
pensions military pensions included are
looked at in matters of divorce when the
in in property
division representative Greg thank you
Mr chairman this question is actually
for you is there can we ask if there's
somebody that can define disposable
retired pay because that changes the
entire trajectory trajectory of the
questioning if and I'm afraid we've put
the good representative hot seat here so
would you mind stepping back and U sir
could you come up and Define that thank
you than thank you very much thank you
for that that was wonderful we're going
you stay for the record your name please
uh thank you
m oh you got to turn the mic on that's
the hard part my name is uh Larry
Larry white okay I'm a retired major in
the United States Air Force I'm a second
career lawyer although I'm not admitted
in the state of New Hampshire um uh the
reason I speak to you is on behalf of
250,000 retired military personnel male
female who are affected by this bill
Nationwide but I also am subject to this
bill personally in that I was married
and divorced in the state of New
Hampshire uh I thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak to you today uh
if you would like I can address
specifically the military the depos
military pay issue
essentially and I appreciate the
comments made by the previous gentleman
uh representative mil disposable
military pay is basically the retired
pay which is based on a number of years
of service and rank of the individual
minus a insurance program that benefits
the spouse it's called The spouse's
benefit program SBP and essentially is
uh life insurance for the spouse both
former spouses and regular spouses so
it's shared between the two parties it
then is also subject to uh subtraction
of any disability pay that the service
member retired service member has uh and
this was recently upheld this specific
language and this handling of it being
mandatorily excluded was just upheld by
the US Supreme Court about 5 years ago
so that's where you get the
Disposable uh retirement pay uh
emphasize the word retirement pay uh I
think representative Raymond for her
quote to the history of this the U eisa
as we say the uniform services former
spouses protection act in that nowhere
in there does it say the word pension
military retirement pay is not a
pension it is money earned by the
military member retired military member
and in the language of both the New
Hampshire Supreme Court I believe uh but
the US Supreme
Court it is reduced compensation for
reduced service the military member is
subject to mandatory
recall I as a retired officer retired
regular officer I have no choice if I am
recalled I must serve my specialty has
been recalled in previous Wars I was an
electronic warfare officer uh which is a
very very highly Technical and
specialized field but again remember I'm
speaking not for the Air Force I'm
speaking on my own personal
uh
interests so uh as we talked about the
history of this and it follows a US
Supreme Court decision in 1981 called
McCarthy B McCartney that held that for
various reasons and they did the
analysis now in introducing this bill we
introduce you to the concept the fact
that the terms
the military retirement pay as property
for purposes of divorce settlement and
then it flips right back and it's taxed
as pay to us so we look at it first as
property and then we look at as pay and
then it changes back again it could be
used for various things I'd like to
stress now right now that we are not
advocating for two things we are not
advocating for any changes to child
support in any ways anything that would
harm children nor are we against the
concept of alimony determined by a judge
as appropriate in the circumstances we
are against mandatory non-changing
non-terminating
payments as I said I was divorced in New
Hampshire in 2001 I am still after 24
years of divorce still paying my ex-wife
$2,000 a month I've paid in excess of
$400,000 in this payment when does it
stop okay when does it stop how much
longer am I going to be paying this if
you look you've asked about the uh
what's handled Nationwide the states
look at it very differently effect
effectively in Texas there is no alimony
anymore some other states are limiting
it now the trend and you compos very
very appropriately and I thank you for
that in 1970 1980 lifetime lifetime
alimony was very common then it's much
less common today in fact and we know at
least seven states have specifically put
on there that lifetime alimony will no
longer be granted five years is a very
common thing because alimony is designed
to be rehabilitative okay meaning that
it's a chance for the spouse to make up
for any any benefits lost to go to
school to get a skill to get a job and I
think is very appropriate as was said
before I think our characterization of
this is not taking anything away in fact
we're giving greater Al giving greater
opportun to judges to create a
specific solution to each specific
situation but what I tell you that the
languages it currently now does is
for uh
female uh service members right now they
comp compose about 18% of the Armed for
armed services the United States and of
that 250,000 people I've talked about
whose interests I represent to some
extent they're about 18% % of that is no
what this what if you don't change the
bill what happens for a div
divorced single mom who is having to pay
this money if she was abused in her
marriage she is now forced to pay her
abuser for Lifetime forced to pay her
abuser for
lifetime because the way it's
interpreted and applied in the states
and most New Hampshire courts through my
experience you have that situation again
we are trying to give more flexibility
in this if it's property then it should
be property if it's income it should be
income so I and the previous gentleman
uh representative characteriz this this
is an ongoing thing for those of you
familiar with the divorce process when
we look at the marital assets for most
people they have pension plans that are
subject to RIS urisa which is the the
national law on that military retirement
pay is not a RIS of plan it has no value
it has nothing can be divorced one time
major white we're coming up on a uh a
bump to the next hearing so uh would you
take some questions please seem to have
the answers representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
is this uh disposable retired pay
considered taxable income via the
federal government on a 1040 yes ma'am
it's actually not on a 1040 4 on a 1099
1099 thank you representative Raymond
thank you so under the current language
does the judge have the discretion to
order 0% or 5% or some other number that
isn't 50% the judge has that but there's
an understanding that with this language
in the bill that many state court judges
and I've talked to many of them all
across the nation they think they're
actually required
to theoretically though a judge could do
that but I've not heard of anyone doing
that quite frankly thank you anyone else
yes uh representative how do I pronounce
your name Georges Georges Mary thank you
thank you m Mr chairman uh thank you
for your presentation I just want to
know like you say you you are divorce
with your wife and then you continue to
to pay and the wife even the the wife is
married or have someone
has this is unlike normal divorces where
remarriage now the other thing is is my
wife completed a successful career my
ex-wife completed a successful career as
a uh teacher here in New Hampshire she's
retired she has her own pension from
that her pension could not be considered
in the divorce because of New Hampshire
law so mine was hers wasn't and mine's
not even a pension
if I violate this if I no longer become
eligible for military service I go to a
different country I renounce my American
citizenship my payments are done I have
to be available to serve in the military
she has no such
condition representative
rice thank you Mr chairman so in
deciding when the spouse gets the half
of the of the the Disposable retired pay
is there a certain certain length of
time the marriage had to be intact well
not really ma'am but under the under the
eisa law for the federal government to
recognize it there has to be an overlap
of 10 years of the military service and
the marriage but that only affects the
payment by the federal government
directly to the EXP spouse um some State
Court judges have said that that doesn't
apply to state law and will order the
division anyways but under the federal
law there should be the 10-year overlap
between the milit service in the
marriage thank you and if if I may if I
keep that if that's meant by the way
military espouses remain eligible for
Commissary for medical care for dental
care under the armed for services they
don't lose that and we are not
contesting that in any way
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for the
explanation and for your testimony and
taking my question so in looking I just
looked up some stuff I'm having a hard
time wrapping my brain about the uh
disposal retired pay and I think I have
a comprehension of it but one of the
things that it's used to pay is child
support alimony or divide property so in
this case and and by the way in many
divorces there's alimony whatever
else what if this is what's usually to
pay for this how would the person
because you're you're upset I mean I
understand that you've been paying
alimon for a very long time and that's a
problem so
what how does alimony get paid than
otherwise would it just not come out of
this because many I know a lot of people
in the military um who their spouse is
not working because of the travel and
everything else and raising the kids so
they sacrifice their occupation to
uphold their spouses occupation and help
them with that so what what is the
exchange on that or what's the because
this I'm I'm seeing the same thing the
shall not include so how do this get
paid I I appreciate your situation but
not every spouse suffers in the military
of a military member some
sorry sorry I would just want to clarify
for the record I did not say suffers at
all sacrific I mean not all of them do
not all of them sacrifice for something
I mean they their careers go on
unimpeded and in fact the the laws uh
federal laws over the last uh years or
state laws for example they're
encouraging uh transference of
credentials such as for lawyers such for
nurses much easier so they don't all
suffer and I think that goes back to the
incident that each case is individual
there should not be a blanket coodie
cutter approach to it which we are
trying to avoid in this um now here's
where it flips from property to uh
income that they do the property
division first okay which is the monthly
income and this is monthly every month
it's determined have the conditions been
met has it's done so now after that now
it flips back to income and they can
compute child support and uh alimony if
appropriate under state law after that
so the same pay is used twice it's
competed once for property and once for
income we agree that that income
characterization is appropriate and
should be calculated as again I said
we're not opposed to alimony as a
concept generally and certainly not
opposed to child support in any way so
we're just opposed to the fact that it
should not be first divided as property
then what's left over is then divided as
last
call thank you major for your testimony
and appreciate it appreciate the
opportunity to speak to everybody thank
you for your questions and I'm an Air
Force Major as well thank you for your
service sir it was
that's the hardest part of testifying
it's turning the light on you'll see a
little red light which means you've won
oh red is good thank you I was I saw it
red and I turned it right off that's the
that's the hard part that was there we
go so my name's Anna gay Zimmerman um
and I am here today because I practice
family law for a very long time stopped
doing it about a year and a half ago um
which is much less stressful in my
personal life but I have a very I I did
a lot of work with military def pensions
I represented a lot of military members
and I represented a lot of military
spouses uh I wrote a paper several years
ago many years ago now called divorce in
the trenches and I you know I've
testified as an expert on how when a a
pension can be divided how it gets
divided things like that um I am also a
former military
spouse um divorced also I will say that
that my ex-husband was not in the
military long enough we had about eight
years so we did not have any issue of
dividing up pensions I did not have so I
have
no I don't know dog in this fight so to
speak but I have a lot of concerns about
this bill so let me talk and I know I
only got three minutes so I'm going to
try to talk real big picture first um
you've talked about what disposable
retirement pay is we take the entire
retirement benefit we reduce the SBB
premium if an SBP is being awarded and
or has been agreed upon that's the
Survivor benefit if it's not then that
doesn't happen a big one that comes out
though is um any amounts getting paid
for VA uh benefits or VA disability so
you might have a $4,000 pension
someone's got a 25% VA disability and
that pensions getting reduced by $600 a
month $700 a month something like that
that is now um since a case called how
versus howl US Supreme court case in
2017 since that time that military
pension doesn't get divided our state
court doesn't have an option on that
that that that portion of the military
pension it's called a VA waiver
basically you get the money U from the
VA instead it becomes non- taxable but
it gets deducted from your military
pension for people who have a disability
over 50% it's different it's paid on top
but that's how it works for those kind
of lower rating disabilities so that is
already moved over here on the and put
in the pile of the military spouse can't
be touched by the court for the purposes
of property division what this bill is
proposing is that then well then what
happens is we look at all the pensions
all the retirement benefits that are
available to be divided this gentleman
who just talk spoke talked about his
wife's teacher retirement the only way
that was not subject to this court the
Court's division is if it was if it was
acquired either before or after the
marriage otherwise she would would have
been entitled to her Hodgkin share a
percentage of the share that was
accumulated during the marriage the
exact same thing happens with the
military retirement the only thing the
court is devel is dividing up is the
share that was accumulated during the
marriage and it treats the military
retirement just like it does another
pension because they're inherently hard
to Value hod the Hodgkins case talks
about this as soon as the military
member dies the value disappears so as
as do many pensions um even the state
ones we often see yeah it's got some
cash value but that is not remotely
close to the full value of the pension
and and the pension continues to pay out
over the years until someone passes away
so those get divided regardless of who
owns them a teacher I just didn't want
there to be any confusion that a
teacher's salary or a teacher's pension
might not be subject to the court
because they all are what they're asking
you to do now though is carve out the
military pension and I think if anything
this is more it is not giving the court
leeway to reduce amounts like is being
suggested it is saying it does not count
it like the um VA money it is getting
put in a separate pile not part of the
property division not subject to
Equitable division we already have a
provision that allows the court to do
something Equitable that's different
than 5050 the starting presumption in
New Hampshire is that 5050 is is what's
Equitable but the court is allowed to
deviate from that so if we've got the
abused spouse who's been beaten by her
husband who's raising a kid alone he's
not allowed to see the kids anymore and
he's got you know she has a very very
low-paying job and he's got a
high-paying job the court can already
equate for that and give her more of
something to keep her be at her pension
or something else to adjust for this the
one thing I would say about that is
federal law does not allow for more than
50% of the Disposable retire pay to be
allocated to the uh non-military spouse
so there is a cap it can't be more than
that although that could happen with
other pens other types of Pensions um my
experience as a military
spouse and it's a little con concerning
to me to hear the characterizations of
of military spouses because it is a true
partnership I have many many many
friends who have been at home losing
sleep taking care of kids for you know
multiple years will they had deployed
husbands or wives not sure if those
people were going to come home to them
who are getting moved every few years to
a new Duty station who never stay long
enough somewhere to get their own
pension built up somewhere or retirement
because they are as committed to that
job and their country as their spouses
and that is just part of the military
lifestyle um I only lived at for short
period of time compared to what a lot of
people live it but people are living
that every single day and this is not
alimony for life this is a benefit that
you accumulate just like any other
pension just like any state retirement
that you accumulate as part of your
service and this law would take strip
that right from those military spouses
and treat it different than everything
else that I know I'm out of time so out
of time would did you take some
questions coun ABS questions
representative Gabby GR
SM thank you chairman um thank you uh
Miss Zimmerman for coming to um speak
with us um so this would take
out that benefit and your last sentence
what discretion would the court then
have it would have none the way it's
worded it is not considered part of the
property that the court would be
equitably
dividing thank you yeah any other
questions
sing none thank you Council app
that chair
recognizes Kevin
correct thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I am a 25y
year Air Force veteran I am a 27y year
veteran of the town of hookit New
Hampshire and since this is a committee
I don't see a lot uh I wanted to tell
you that I I I represent the state
veterans advisory committee um their
legislative chair and every year what we
do is I go through and figure out in
this particular legislative session
there are 17 bills that we feel have
better an impact we get together we take
a position on those bills and then I
come and I Tell You Folks what our
position on those things is we're we're
actually uh chartered by state law RSA
115 col and a 8 if you want to read up
on us you can also get get a uh get to
us through the the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
website you can also get through us that
way we in the State Vet advisory
committee had the language on this bill
we did not take a position on it we were
very uh hesitant to do that so our
official position is that we're
following this bill meaning we're just
going to wait and see which direction
that the wind blows okay so the official
sbac position is that this uh that we're
going to follow this and see what
happens now with your permission I would
like to take off my state veterans
advisory committee hat and talk to you
as Kevin Grady fighter pilot
representative of uh of myself in the
town of hooks at New Hampshire the chair
considers you now hatless thank you sir
full disclosure I am like a previous
person here uh divorced I have been
paying a a percentage of my military
retirement uh to a former spouse for a
lot of years now and the situation that
happened when I got married or when I
got divorced was that I still had
approximately eight or nine more years
on active duty before any of this
started happening okay what I wanted to
do is kind of bring you up to speed a
little bit on on what's in the former
spouse's protection act why did it
happen and and what changes have been
made to it to make it Equitable um the
it was passed in late ' 81 and it became
effective in in 1982 and what it was
meant to do is protect that military
spouse that bounced around and bounced
around and bounced around you know and
they they were in the military for 25
years together and then at that point
they get divorced and here's somebody
who's 45 years old with no work
experience no work history no pension no
nothing that now is sitting out there so
this this former spouse's Act was set up
to protect that person from uh from that
happening and
essentially it has been revised in 1986
they they they took the disability pay
out of there and with the
2017 um uh National Defense
authorization act they did something
that that actually would have helped me
uh I got divorced as a relatively Junior
major and I retired as a colonel and my
former spouse is getting retirement pay
at the colonel rate okay that would have
helped me but that you're that's not
applicable because only divorces after
2017 are covered by this latest change
okay now I I view that whole situation
as not everybody is made to be married
to somebody that's in the military and
better to find out you know sooner than
later okay and and what what the what
the law generally allowed for was either
a lumpsum amount every month that could
be agreed upon or it allowed for a
percentage and typically the percentage
is we start with 50% for the member and
then they do just a pretty much how many
years were you married to this person
that's in the military well 10 how many
years did they serve well 20 well you
get you get 50% of the remaining half or
25% that's the way that the formulas
tend to work on this kind of of
legislation the the federal law as it's
already written and this is really
important the federal law as it's
already written already gives a local
judge discretion to either include this
include this or not to follow formulas
or not to make up their own percentage
what they think is fair based on the the
circumstances of each individual case
that already exists in the law and as
you have all pointed out that if you if
you pass this HB 170 you're you're
taking that off the table now um I have
uh when I started talking at my house
about this bill uh my my military spouse
wife got kind of fired up about it and
she would like to talk to you not
necessarily next but at some point so
subject to your questions that's really
all I want to
um I think my last pink card is Frank
okay good afternoon committee members my
name is Frank Kin I'm from Northampton
Ura Good Day committee members I stand
before you today as a constituent of the
Granite State my purpose is to request
your consideration to listen and share
to an ongoing mission to write or wrong
again I'm a retired military veteran of
21 years and one of over 250,000
retirees affected by the federal law 10
US code 1408 payment of retired or
retainer pay in compliance with court
orders the egregious result is that that
for over 40 years the law is literally
picking the pockets of veterans and will
do for life I've been paying my former
spouse longer than we were actually
married she has since remarried and
divorced another military veteran and is
currently in another long-term
relationship and has inherited her
father's
estate briefly I'd like to state that
the state of New Hampshire set
precedents back in 1980 with the baker
Baker decision and the baker Baker
decision with military retirement prior
to to the former spouse law states
military retirement pay lacks the
following characteristics of property
cash surrender value loan value
Redemption value lump sum value and
value realizable after death that means
that once I die my payments stop now if
my former spouse passes away payments
revert back to me that's not the concept
of property that would be like the boat
at a house being awarded to my former
spouse she passes away and I go to her
new husband and say hey I need that back
it doesn't work that way retirement pay
does that so it doesn't fit any kind of
description of what property is yet it's
classified it magically turns into
income first it's property or first it's
income then it's property then it comes
back to income again what this law is
trying to do is level a playing field
take it off as property we have no
problem using it as income to help a
forance spouse out and provide for for
child care child support all it does is
it ends at one at one particular time
alimony ends child support ends if you
take the if you divide the military
retirement as property what's left and
then tax it as alimon and child support
there's no military retirement left now
there's stipulations just as Larry
stated out I'm subject to recall if I
refuse recall they take my pay if I get
incarcerated for more than 30 days they
take my pay if I uh relinquish my
citizenship they take my pay they stop
my pay if I go to work for the Saudi
government fixing
f-15s without a waiver from the
secretary of the Navy they stop my pay
now on the flip side if my former spouse
was to say the heck with it I don't want
to be a US citizen I'm going to marry an
Australian go live in Australia now
she's an Australian citizen they send a
check to her bank account okay now she
gets tired of her husband and divorces
him or he has an accident she gets
incarcerated in prison guess what they
send the checks right to the prison so
this is the inequities that's with this
this particular law um they saw fit back
in the 70s to do that to kind of take
care of the former spouses that didn't
have anything but times have changed uh
we have a lot more military veterans
that are female that are getting
hammered by this law um the Abuse Act
that involves a military retirement if
the service member commits domestic
violence they lose their retirement pay
yet the abused former spouse gets it now
Flip Flip the rules if you have the
service members being abused by the
civilian
spouse right and they get divorced you
still have to pay that spouse that's
abusing
you it doesn't make sense so what we're
saying is the baker Baker
law calls out hey it's not property it's
income um I'll be happy to take any
kland seeing none thank you for your
service and thank you for coming today
we will not go to Executive session on
this I think we need some more time to
think it through this ends the hearing
on House Bill 170 and I now call
into
exist I do not have another pink card on
this
okay I think it probably got combined
okay thank you Mr chairman and thank you
ladies and gentlemen I appreciate giving
being given the opportunity to speak
today my name is Roberta Grady and I am
a resident of
hookit I'm not going to speak directly
to the law but I'm here to tell you my
story so that you have an idea of what
it's like to be a military spouse and
yes I was a military spouse a while ago
but some things don't
change in
1980 I became a military spouse for the
first time I was living here in New
Hampshire I was a retail manager and I
was on the verge of a really great
promotion but I fell in love with a guy
in the Army and I married him and moved
to
Alabama but it was a short-term move and
I couldn't get a job it just wasn't
feasible it was only temporary so we
moved to Germany and I couldn't get a
job in retailing because all of the
onbase jobs went to Germans per the
status of forces agreement and off base
I didn't speak German I wasn't going to
get a job in a German store so what
could I do well I I was lucky I found a
job I changed careers and I became a
part-time instructor after working for a
contractor for the army and eventually I
did get promoted but there was no
retirement plan for me there was no
pension for me with that job we stayed
in Germany for 5 years which is at least
two years longer than most people get to
stay in any one area and we moved to
Texas and I was lucky once again I found
a job but it was a part-time job no
pension no promotion available for me so
I went to night school to get my
Master's degree and while I was in
school my husband who was deployed to to
um Honduras actually at the time called
me and told me we were getting a divorce
and I became very quickly a former
military spouse and by the way when I
was in Germany the first time I worked
as a volunteer a lot with military
spouses and I was in favor of the former
military spouse protection act never
knowing that eventually maybe I might
need it but we weren't married long
enough for me to take advantage of that
I was an advocate for it and I still
am at any rate after I was divorced I
decided I would stay in school finish my
degree and stay in the area and I was
lucky enough to get two
jobs with a one with a defense
contractor but it was a a temporary job
no payment no pension plan no promotion
eligible for me you get the picture here
I wasn't able to acrew wealth the way
most most people are who stay in a
career field or who stay in one place
long for a period of
time at the time I was uh working for
the contractor I met Kevin my husband
and I became once again a military
spouse I moved to a temporary assignment
with no job available and then we were
stationed on okoa Japan I found a great
mentor I was hired as a contractor to
help other military spouses overcome the
same relocation issu isues I was having
but no pension no retirement pain and no
chance for a promotion eventually my
mentor transferred back to the States
and I was able to get her job which was
a temporary civil service position it
was my job to help military spouses find
employment I had clients from all walks
of life and their their military spouses
were everything from Junior enlisted to
senior officers but one day I had a
client in my office and I will never
forget she came into my office trying to
figure out how to apply for a job in her
chosen career field see she was a
dentist she' left a promising valuable
career a practice in Southern California
with the idea that she'd be able to get
okola Military dentists have those jobs
she didn't speak Japanese she wasn't
going to become a Japanese dentist
she sat in my office and as I had to
explain the reality to her that her
chances of being a dentist were
effectively
nil she was angry she was confused she
was afraid she didn't know what she was
going to
do that's not just one
instance I was a career counselor for
military spouses both on okano and then
back again in Germany I saw literally
hundreds of spouses in that same kind of
position where their same career field
it was heartbreaking to talk to that
woman I will never forget her face but
again it was not Comm uncommon we give
up a lot as military
spouses we
move we have to decide whether to move
with our spouses or to stay put and
raise children or live alone without our
spouses we deal with
deployments we're very often either
unemployed or underemployed and again no
chance to acrew wealth through a pension
plan not for
us we if we don't move with our military
spouse we live in a community where
maybe nobody understands what it's like
to be a military spouse and so we don't
have that community that sense of
support that is so
important we struggle to find child care
just like civilians we sometimes put up
with substandard housing now no spouse
enters into a marriage thinking it's
going to end
we all hope for the best when we say
those vows and Military spouses are no
different but it happens and when it
does a military spouse should have the
ability to have a Judge review whether
or not they're eligible to share in
their members retirement pay just as the
federal law allows it is a small price
for the sacrifices we make it is
fair this New Hampshire legislature has
done many good things for military
spouses and I thank you for that you've
made
licensing um easy for easier for
military spouses that's really really
critically important you know what we
contribute to this state and to our
country are you willing to take any
questions I am
any okay thank you thank you very much
now there are no more pink cards so I am
closing the hearing on House Bill 170
and am opening the hearing on House Bill
Murphy with I might add some very
distinguished
I think you need to fill out a pink card
but do it after I did you did yep it's
coming
wire would the owner of a blue phone
please
approach tell me one secret about what's
look you're only a
[Laughter]
co-p we do have fun
here good afternoon Mr chair and
honorable committee members I'm
representative Dancy Murphy
representative from the town of marac
Hillsboro County District
12 I'm happy to come before your
committee today for the first time in
quite a while um and to have the
opportunity to do so relative to subject
matter special education and Foster
parenting that have impacted my own life
um in my personal and uh for personal
and professional reasons as a former
foster parent and adoptive parent of
children with disabilities who received
special education services over the the
years and a result of my experience in
my former role uh at New Hampshire's
DCF I recognize the value of committed
foster parents in educational
decisionmaking for children in care who
are without legal parents to fulfill
that role I also recognize the need to
have our special education laws written
in such a way that limits confusion and
makes intent clear it is likely for that
reason that a constituent with a great
deal of experience and expertise in the
special education Arena requested that I
file this bill relative to clarifying
confusing language in New Hampshire
special ed statute RSA chap 186 c
section 14a paragraph 1 um she is here
actually and will also testify I've
provided copies of the current statute
with the confusing language that this
bill seeks to remove highlighted and
italicized in blue though your copies
say red as they were printed not color
thank you for that thank you appreciate
it not in color it only had blue
highlighter so apologies just further
confuse that this bill um though HB 178
addresses statute um relative to the
appointment of foster parents to make
educational decisions on behalf of uh
children in their placement it changes
nothing substantive about the policy it
merely removes confusing redundant
language to better clarify the statutes
meaning as you can see the line that's
crossed out that he or she has the
Knowledge and Skills to represent the
child adequately in
Services appears in the in introductory
sentence of the statute that same phrase
is included in subsection 4 as written
the introductory sentence is confusing
and given it also appears later within
the same section is redundant and
unnecessary HB 178 simply seeks to just
remove those 16 words so that the
statute is more clear I ask that you
support an OT Mo OTP motion on hb178
thank you for your time and attention I
am so glad that you said what you just
did both the red par isn't you know that
that I appreciate that but also I was so
afraid that you would say you can
represent the child even if you don't
have the skills to do it and that didn't
sound very nice right but what you're
saying is right there in front of me in
plain sight in bold letters the language
is still there we're still looking for
people who are capable to do it you're
just removing a redundancy exactly
changes nothing about the statute see
I'm supposed to ask you a question so
would you believe that I would believe
questions thank you thank you so much
Dunham you have 20 handouts are one hand
times thank you I'm Bonnie Dunham I live
in miramac New Hampshire and um I'm glad
to be able to be here today I've been an
educational surrogate parent for two
children um and I also conducted the
training for about 10 years for
parents who wanted to become educational
surrogate parents I always say
educational surrogate parent because the
the first time I was appointed to a
child I went and met the people he was
living with and I said I'm the surrogate
parent and I know they were wondering
what role I played in his coming into
this world and so I always say that
first I kind of wish it said that anyway
but it doesn't um in the special
education process parents play an
essential role they're members of the
child's individualized education program
team or IEP team and they make decisions
at every step in that process but some
children don't have someone to do that
for them not because the parents are
busy it's only when a parent is unknown
is can't be located or the child is in
the custody of dcyf in that case so that
the child does still have someone
representing them in the parent role
whose only role is to look out for that
child as if they were the parent um in
that process the state is required to
appoint a surrogate parent for that
child and in fact RSA 186c colon 14
establishes that process for training
and appointing a surrogate parent to
represent that child when that child has
a foster parent though and the foster
parent would like to be able to
represent the child and advocate for
them in the special education process
RSA 186c colon 14-a provides a
simplified streamlined process for that
to happen um they don't necessarily have
to go through the N9 9 hour of training
they just need to be able to demonstrate
that they know enough they need to be
they need to pass the test that somebody
would pass after taking that so they can
demonstrate that they can appropriately
represent that child was part of the the
group that that talked about that when
the federal law was changed under the
federal law a foster parent a state can
decide a foster parent is just a parent
in that process we knew several times
though when a when a child was with a
foster parent who wanted to represent
them and 3 months later said I can't
handle this child and gave them up to
another foster parent the child lost
their surrogate parent and their foster
parent and was left in limbo until
someone new was hired and so that's why
one of the requirements is that they
have to have a long-term relationship
with the child of at least one year so
you know that they they know what
they're in for and they're committed to
that um the idea of having a simplified
process is fantastic but having language
in that first sentence that is
discombobulated and confusing kind of
undoes the simplification of that
process instead of just reading a foster
parent or parents may be appointed by
the commissioner of the Department of
Education or someone else right in the
middle of that it says a foster parent
may be appointed by the commissioner of
the Department of Education that he or
she has the knowledge to represent the
child adequately in services or
designate so C somebody cut and pasted
it in there by mistake it's just fixing
an error and this sentence fixes that
and the requirement that they have
Knowledge and Skills still exists okay
any questions in the interest of
combobulation yes I was talking to my
wife the other day when do you ever hear
that word thank you for that word any
witness seeing none thank you very
much do we all want to stand up and
shout hooray uh this okay uh this ends
the hearing on House Bill 178 and now I
am going to open the ex ex session and
the chair moves ought to pass I'd like
to have a Democrat second right over
there representative Greg had the hand
up almost immediately any further
discussion seeing none would one of our
two clerks call the
role yes I'm sorry uh two clerks no
waiting I am the motion is ought to pass
um moved by the chair and seconded by
178 Mr chairman would you like to go
first or last I would enjoy going
first
yes Mr chairman still
Yes representative deimon
rice representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson myself yes
representative sidel yes representative
love yes representative coren yes
representative marel yes representative
patrino yes representative Gman yes
representative
LC representative
levac not here got it representative
representative
Raymond representative George's yes
okay that's teamwork hey we have might
easy good one to start with our first of
the new year I'll take it 15 to zero
with one absence one absence and this is
where you say would the person who made
the motion write out the committee
report or you cannot go
home that would be
you me
Oh I thought so when I okay all right
I'm G to close the exact session on
House Bill 178 await your paperwork and
open the hearing on House Bill 204
relative to criteria for reporting child
support delinquencies to federal
fainer oh thank you uh any objections to
that going on consent hearing none thank
you hey representative Murphy come back
anytime this was fun you're welcome
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee this will look familiar in
fact all three of them that I'm going to
be presenting today going to look
familiar uh this bill is exactly as it
passed this committee last term exactly
as it passed the Senate after passing
the house floor uh the Senate made a
minor amendment I kept that amendment in
here to match what the Senate wanted the
only problem with it was we couldn't
come to a uh an agreement when it came
back to the house because it was
apparently co-mingled with some other
things that we had to concur with
and uh it got non-c
concurred but this is the bill that
addresses a situation that uh I
experienced personally where uh we
identified and and it was confirmed uh
in the Senate when uh the chairman the
chairwoman of the committee over there
uh asked for more information from the
department and uh gave them a week to
come up with proof that it didn't happen
and they were not able to provide such
proof and she made her Amendment and
passed it out of the Senate this the
situation at hand is that uh the uh
Department of
um Child Support
Services expects the payment every week
and some of us are paid every two weeks
so every now and then in the middle of
the year it looks like we're short by
about
$5 and I went to go uh with a new job
get a passport renewed sent my passport
off and my wages are garnished so my I
had no way I could fall behind um and uh
I was notified by the state department
down in Washington that they were not
going to renew my passport because I was
behind on my child support I said well
how could that be and when I called they
said oh yeah you're off by I think it
was like $6 and change something like
that um I actually had given last term
the the figures and proof copy to the uh
chairman so he could actually see the
veracity of the
misalignment um and uh I had to pay that
$6 and change wait a few days and then
ask the state department to please query
the state again to see if I had was up
to date so that I could get my passport
and if I waited too long it could have
gone through another pay cycle and I
might have been off again so what we're
trying to do uh is fix that problem by
ensuring that one the dollar amount is
actually reported because when I was in
discussion with the uh state department
they said we don't know what the amount
is that you're in a rear we just get
told that either red light green light
when we ask them if you're behind or on
time and um we never get reported the
amount so we couldn't say oh that's just
a rounding error or that's a problem you
know not really a delinquency we'll go
ahead and process it so we're asking
that with this bill that the agency if
they report to the federal government a
delinquency does report the dollar
amount and that they do not report
delinquencies unless they actually meet
the federal threshold that they say that
they are meet they are not reporting
unless they meet um I know currently
that they're going to come up and
testify that they do not report these
unless they hit a certain threshold and
it's pretty high but it happened to me
so I know that somehow it gets reported
and it happens so I want to make sure
that we hold them to the threshold that
they say they meet already by put
putting it in the statute and I want to
make sure that we also make them report
the dollar amount so that if the
situation pops up that it's $5 short the
state department down in the federal
government doesn't say oh this person's
delinquent they can say oh that's a
rounding
error and Mr chairman I seem to remember
when we did this dance once before you
were pointing out to me others for whom
this had happened in other words you're
not some poor individual solo sucker
correct there was a question as to
whether this only happened for me but
your committee researcher actually got
that data for your your committee and I
do not remember what the numbers were
but I'm sure she could make that
available again to the committee I'm
sure she'd love
to to to show you that it happens
approximately I don't know a 100 or so
times to citizens of New Hampshire every
year so any
questions for the representative
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for being here and sharing your story
again so I I'm going to have one
question and then followup so get ready
for my followup okay just go like this a
followup okay whenever you uh came
before us last time and shared your
story it was you said 4 cents so what is
the amount that you were it it was the
four the 4 cents was a um it could be as
low as 4 cents is what I had said
because it can be actually as low as
just a couple of pennies if if the G if
it's a red light not a green light
saying the person is not o paid over
their current uh due amount or paid at
that level if it's behind by as little
as 4 cents it gets a red light and and
gets denied my case I think I don't
remember what the amount was we had the
paperwork all in front of you U Mr
chairman last time but it was $6 and
change or so something to that effect
followup there's my followup or my crazy
sign um thank you for uh letting me
follow up so I also have a question
because I I remembered your thing we
talked outside of this about this and so
I went and asked a ton of people about
that I know that have have had their
issue you know that have um been paying
child support have they ever lost their
passport um I found one person he was
2600 which he met the federal threshold
of 2500 I couldn't find anybody that was
close to you as a matter of fact
whenever they got below 2500 they were
ready to do that so I know that you've
said you provided it for Pearson but is
there some way that you can provide us
documentation showing that that happened
like you could take out your particulars
but showing that it's like $6 because
you said you don't know the amount but
it was $6 but can you show us if I go
dig it up again I can probably find that
and provide it um that would be helpful
because you're the only one I can find
um well I I can tell you that the
numbers that were brought up by your
committee researchers showed that it
happens to a lot of people for very low
amounts uh every single Year and that
was actual State data that she was able
to find in a day it wasn't very didn't
take very long um so it does happen it
does happen to a lot of people and um
it's not the other issue with that
threshold is it doesn't automatically
clear me again if it goes below the
threshold you have to actually
proactively call and tell them you're
now Bel below it so where I was
garnished I wouldn't have even known
that I was reported until I went to
renew my passport there is no proactive
mechanism within the department to say
to me we've reported you for
delinquency nor is there one to clear me
if I'm no longer delinquent so falling
behind and and the way it lines up I get
paid every two weeks at the beginning of
the year I'm dead even by the middle of
the Year nothing lines up and I'm always
delinquent a certain amount by the end
of the year it catches right up again
and it's 100% lined up well by the end
of the year it lines up again I'm no
longer delinquent but they're not going
to clear me so that could carry on for
years until I proactively call them and
say hey would you double check and and
clear me from the delinquency because
anymore representative rice thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so you were never you had never
reached the threath threshold of a rear
ages of $2500 correct because I was
garnished and my pay never hit that um
it was always taken out but it was I
couldn't understand it until I started
lining up how much were they expecting
each week with how much was getting sent
by my company every two weeks and
realizing that it it was going down but
it was never more than um 20 some odd
dollars in the very middle of the year
that it misaligned by and at the time
that I asked for the passport I think it
was $6 and change that I had to pay them
over the phone um so that I could become
zero so that I could then call the state
department in Washington and have them
issue the passport so I could go to my
new job in Canada um and visit the
office and run for yes followup okay
thank you representative rice a
else thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee I am
hoping third time a charm on
this and attorney Matthew
Hayes from the Bureau of Child Support
Services legislative
liaison and part of the beauty pageant
this
morning thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon um so it's at the outset I'm
aware that this bill's been was coming
through this committee last year and
just want to state that the bureau is
neutral on this bill um I did not put
that I had much I figured there's going
to be questions so I wasn't going to say
that much again we're neutral on the
bill we feel like we're already
complying with it and if the
legislature feels it's appropriate to
pass this legislation uh we have no
opposition in other words it might not
help arguably but it won't
hurt uh I don't see how it could hurt I
like I said I I think that the program
is already
reporting in compliance with federal
guidelines um the system is set up in a
way where it
reports
the arear to the federal child support
agency when they reach a certain
threshold like I we've all spoken about
many times so in this case 2500 when it
gets to that point that gets reported to
the federal agency uh child sport agency
and then I realize this is speculative
but how might you account for chairman
Spain's problem and that of maybe a
hundred other people I I I can't really
speak to anyone's specific case I'm not
even allowed to due to confidentiality I
don't know um why that if if that I I
really can't speak I don't know they
shouldn't know about it sorry oh then
let's move to a hypothetical of a
citizen of undetermined name were
reported for 50
and yet the threshold is 2500 how might
that be occurring I I don't know I mean
it's a it's electronically transmitted
so I don't I think there's no person
that's doing it so um it gets you know
the balances get electronically
transferred to the federal child support
agency
and they send it along to the applicable
federal agency in this case would be the
Department of State and um they would
put the hold on the passport um and then
it would be continuously the balances
would be reported every month I believe
every month to the federal agency and if
it reached
zero um then it would drop off or if
somebody wanted to reach out to the case
officer and ask about it um maybe some
other sort of arrangement can be made
with the state agency okay so it's more
of a caseby casee basis representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um you made a
statement that said that when the aages
reach zero it just drops off does that
mean that your agency does not
specifically report to the federal
government that the aages are now in a
zero status
uh thank you for the question and that's
a really good question um and you have
to understand I'm not really an expert
on the technology piece of it but it's
my understanding um that yeah the
balance it's I think of it in my head as
almost like it's coded in a certain way
so if it's zero if the rears are zero
then it should go to the federal child
sport agency as zero and then they
should take it off that's my
understanding of the program the
information that we've submitted to this
Committee in the past is stated if it's
zero the passport should be
returned
um but if it's not zero then then then
yeah if it it could theoretically be a
small balance that's causing it to stay
revoked and I think that's what you were
probably getting at perhaps yeah follow
up thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my followup I just want to make
this clear clear in my head thank you um
so you're not sure if the
specific um data entry is made to notify
the federal
government that it has reached a zero
status is that correct no I think that
they were told it's zero if it is zero
when it gets reported I just don't know
exactly it wise
like like how the computer tells the
other computer if you will uh like how
that exactly looks but the balances
would show zero and that should trigger
the federal agency
to Res restore the passport one more one
more thank you so it could be as low as
um what we heard testimony as 4 cents
and the person would be denied a um a
passport because of 4 cents is that
correct I'm not sure about 4 cents uh I
I will what I can say is that
confidently based on what how the
program
works if it hypothetically went over
2500 let's say and then it got
revoked if it later on in the case
history somebody was paying it down and
they were doing a good job but it was
let's say when it got reported it was
$200 balance it would stay the same
until reached zero or if the state
agency says uh codes it with a
restoration like Flags it for saying no
we worked something out restore it and
again I'm I'm trying to paraphrasing how
computers would essentially it would be
coded probably in a way that would make
them do that there's no person that
would call them and say anything does
that make sense thank you you did a
great job representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here in your test testimony
there are a few things that just broke
my brain last year and this was one of
them and looking at it and with the
amendment like I think it's fine and
everything but my concern is if this is
happening certainly on a grander scale
than one where the breakdown is because
this would technically have to break in
two Tech spaces right first your
reporting and then the federal
also because it goes through it's almost
like two steps to do this correct thank
you for the question um I hadn't thought
of it that way personally but that's a
good point um you the systems would in
theory in theory be talking to each
other and it would I'm not sure how it
would look on their end if I mean they
would be given like I said they would be
given a balance they wouldn't be given a
balance unless it met the threshold and
once they were in the threshold so they
shouldn't they shouldn't see something
that they shouldn't see in a case
that never met that threshold I don't I
don't know why that would happen like I
said it's at some point it becomes an it
question I'm not really sure but that's
not how the system should
work representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you attorney Hayes
for taking my question so my question is
about that threshold right so is the
child support agency the state reporting
every month everybody who's in AAR to
the federal or are they only reporting
the ones that start that hit that $2,500
threshold and then I I have a followup
after that if what whichever the answer
is okay let him answer then waave at me
okay thank you thank you for the
question um that's also a really good
question they it has they have to meet
the threshold first okay um and
that not to make it more confusing but
there is other
thresholds um and the most the other
common one is the TA intercept that
one's a little bit lower so that one was
$500 so it it would
be it it' be it could be different
thresholds but let's maybe just for
Simplicity stick with it what we've been
talking about yeah it they wouldn't know
about it unless it meant to threshold
okay so for thank you Mr chairman so for
someone who is
consistently behind by a couple hundred
dollars because we know sometimes this
happens you carry a balance you're
trying to get it down are they
consistently being reported again and
again or only if let me rephrase it if
they if they hit the 2500 right but they
pay it down so that it's less than 2500
are they still reported or does that
stop I believe they should they're still
being reported okay until it gets to
zero yeah okay thank you representative
rice thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so do does the division now not notify
aage and and thank you for the question
um they get the notification for the
offset program would would come from
what I believe I believe it's from the
federal child support agency they should
get something from the federal child
support agency saying that they're
they're in the offset program now and it
discuss
it
references the child support program uh
that that notice I haven't seen it but I
know that they get something from the
federal child support program telling
them what the program is that they're
been flagged for followup thank you Mr
chairman
so is that only if they reach the
2500 or if they hit 200 in aages they're
getting a notice so they know I I think
it's only if they meet the threshold in
either the tax one or this one and or or
so they only get that notice from the
federal child boort agency one more
quick sure so I know that there's an
automated telephone line that you can
call here in the state right to find out
how much you get how much is owed how
much is in a rares I know for for me the
person who's supposed to be paid right
does the person that pays are are those
same um I don't know options available
like if they called would it tell them
how much they owed if they were in AAR
because I know for me calling it tells
me how much I'm owed in aares does it
because I don't want to see these people
set up to fail I mean we shouldn't be
waiting till
$2,500 to tell them they're in
AAR you know what I mean like I feel
like that's just setting them up for
failure I agree and I I'd have to check
in on that and I know that there's
notices that they would get from us as
an agency before that about I know
there's a notice of debt that goes out
early on the case as well but I'd have
to I'm not sure about that specific
question if I could get back to you that
that'd be okay okay great thank you so
much I try to type a
notice an email to the group and there
is a group email CFL such and
such I can't successfully do it on my
email account it always kicks out and
the IT department in the state has
worked on this for several years and
they their conclusion is there's got to
be a glitch here
somewhere to which I
agree which leads into the question of
could it be quite possible I that with
certain people in the state there is a
glitch here that is causing something to
happen that shouldn't happen not because
anybody's being bad but a glitch is
happening that was a question I I don't
know representative I and thank you for
the question um you I like I said I'm I
only know how the program works and uh
it's generally what I would tell people
is you know it I I didn't design it so I
really can't get into the if there's a
coding I don't know what kind of issue
there could be but um
certainly I can't get any more specific
from that but it is your testimony that
were this to pass it wouldn't hurt
things yeah I would say that's the
position that I took when I started it's
I right neutral oh sorry that was not
for
you that was me making a point to me
okay sorry yes representative price
thank you Mr chairman so passing this
isn't necessarily going to fix the whole
glitch thing is do you know what I'm
saying like how how would passing this
system I me do we have to make a bill to
say to the Department of um child
support you need to investigate this if
this keeps happening we do I can't I'm
not sure if I can answer that I I don't
think there's a glitch I'm not not aware
of a glitch um but this man has glitch I
can't speak to anybody's particular case
I know that if someone brought something
to our attention we could certainly
speak with them on a caseby Case
basis thank you well folks what do you
think I mean I'm almost ready to quote a
famous politician that says maybe we
just ought to pass this and see what
happens somebody said that and maybe if
this problem goes away this was
successful and if it didn't it didn't
make it worse I mean you want to execute
are we ready to execute do you
think
no thank you very much um I just was a
question if they notice the
parent like there is a notice like a
$60 this would be a question to the like
it was just for for $60 he knows that
like he could not pay no he he owes
there was a notice for him to know he
owes
$6 uh do the child send out notices for
Rees right yeah there's there's we sent
out notices um they wouldn't necessarily
he might not he wouldn't someone
somebody wouldn't necessarily get
multiple notices from the federal state
agent the federal agency that is dealing
with Thresh old and the whole subject we
were just talking about they wouldn't
they wouldn't get multiple notices from
the federal government every month once
they've hit that threshold they get the
notice and then they're on
notice uh we are both straying a bit
from the bill itself and also repeating
ourselves uh one more and then uh we're
going to decide whether we exec or not
representative
um rice thank you Mr follow by the other
one more Coen Coen so are you saying
that all delinquent notices come from
the federal government and not the state
because I'm asking if the state is
sending out notices not the federal
government I want to know if he was sent
a notice that said he owed
$6 before he was surprised by the
federal
government I feel like we're I I'm
trying to be I don't want to com I don't
want to comment on anybody's case I
really don't know about his case what
may he may or may not have received just
try to speak generally when somebody
meets this threshold they get a notice
from the federal government because
those programs are federal programs
there are other notices that people do
get from our
agency
um but they come at different times and
different points in the case for
different
reasons no last one go ahead thank you
Mr chair and thank you for being here
and answering my question um I think my
question is along the same lines as
representative rice so someone's delink
going um and until they reach
$2500 they're still just within the
state what
happens to those people who are less
than
$2500 uh well they went I get thank you
for the question I appreciate that and
that's a that's an interesting question
but basically there are other state
remedies that we have and um we talked
about we can C I can send you more
information about those I mean there's
certainly other things that the bureau
can do
to enforce the cases just one follow but
no um okay uh we we're kicking this
around again and again I just would like
a show of thumbs are we ready to exec
this or not if so thumbs up if
not uh
I think we are okay good thank you and
thank you councelor you've been grilled
thank you Mr chairman and this ends the
uh hearing on House Bill
204 and now I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill wait for it 204
and the chair recognizes representative
motion thank you Mr chairman I move are
to pass and we have a second looking for
somebody from representative George's
welcome to the major
leagues and the motion before us is
House Bill 204 the motion is ought to
pass moved by representative deimon and
seconded by representative
Georges and would the clerk a clerk
please call the role
please thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
yes representative D Simon yes
representative
rice representative McMahon
yes representative Nelson says yes
representative sidel yes representative
love yes representative coren yes
representative marel yes representative
patrino yes representative
Gman absent thank you representative LC
is absent representative Greg yes repres
representative
Raymond representative georgees yes
representative Malone
yes hey 14 Z 14 to nothing with two
absences motion passes is there any
consent I'm educable it took me two
years to recognize her hand you know I'm
getting to thank you edicated now I'm
edicated thank you and representative D
Sone gets a piece of paper from the
clerk so she can write the committee
report on it just as I get one this um
concludes the exec session on House Bill
204 and now I open the hearing on House
Bill
213 relative to wage garnishment for
representative chairman
of fish game and ocean creatures is it
what's me Marine Resources okay
committee thank you
second thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee once again this is a bill
that you all passed through the
committee and we passed through the
house floor last term uh did not make it
through the senate for some reason uh
this one simply is asking the courts
during the final decree period of a
divorce when there is child support
involved to notify the parties that
there is currently a right under our law
for them to not be garnished if they
both choose not to and that's all it
says it basically is because I'm I found
out that I had a right long after I was
told by the court oh no it's automatic
garnishment just happens and it's the
the way we do things and when I was
looking through the
rsas after uh my ex asked me if I could
please prepay for my son's summer camp
and I went to the state and said is
there a way I can send you extra money
for a couple of months extra upfront so
that they could put a down payment on
the summer camp they said no we don't
have a way to handle that if you send us
two months extra we're going to end up
sending it back to you but it'll take a
while so you you're better off just to
uh give it to her and it won't count
towards your child's support but just
give it to her and I said well how come
I can't prepay well you could have made
arrangements they told me to pay
directly to each other and I neither one
of us knew that because were both
getting along quite fine with me just
paying whenever I was due paying her um
so we're we're asking here with this
bill to to say to the judge in the
courtroom that part of the instructions
and the final disposition is let them
know they have a right if they both
agree to not be garnished there are some
uh situations where I've put in here
that they should not be allowed to do
that one if there's a protective order
in place that should not happen one if
the per one of the parties lives out of
state that should not happen and uh one
if the person is already delinquent on
child support from someplace else that
should not happen but in any other
situation if both parties agree I think
they should be told that they have a
right to not be garnished and to avoid
that
system and that's
it any questions for representative spay
and representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative um
I'm trying to recall our specifics and I
have something in my head about a form
being our hang up you guys developed a
form in the committee we did you did did
we create a form I like you designed one
or or explained how it had to be done or
something that both parties would have
that form at the final disposition and
they could both sign into it and it
would have instructions saying that you
know if if you default then you can be
going into garnishment automatically I
don't know if I ever saw that form but I
know that the part the the committee
discussed it and
somebody came with a maybe it was you
rep sidel I I I don't remember but
somebody on the committee actually
contacted me and said we've made a form
so I don't so Mr chairman I could not I
pulled my stuff I had form written down
like 72 times and I found nothing else
and then I was like why did I write down
form can't remember
so yeah somebody got yeah because I
think the only objection from the court
side of things was that they have any
kind of a form for that right and it
says the the court shall create the form
and I think the Judiciary was like we
don't create forms and I think we yeah
that was that was kind of it so yeah
keep going keep going yeah but I do
remember the committee did something
with a form I just don't remember what
it
Mr chairman I assume you're done with my
testimony I'm sorry I assume you're done
with my
testimony
you we do always have people come in
just you know they they're getting
thinking and and they don't want to jump
in too soon representative Greg is one
of those you want you have something to
say yes I don't have a question for him
I have a comment for you Mr chairman
okay um so it's not a question and it's
not for him could we hold that until
anybody with an actual
question seeing none um thank you for
your testimony thank you Mr chairman
again
yeah no no you
can't um are we ready to exec this this
we're not I mean you don't have to be go
ahead I'm concerned because we're
wanting the courts to uh create a new
form this is what this would do that's
going to have a fiscal note on it so I I
don't see anything for a fiscal note or
anything you can't just create a form
and not cost money unfortunately
representative raymon would do it for
nothing no no and she's she's not
legally licensed to do that I don't
think oh um well why don't we does
anybody know how about about our our
committee researcher would you know if
the mere creation of a form would
warrant a fiscal note to the
bill and could you call
somebody for us please and and we'll
come back to this thank you and you have
23 hours it says it takes a day to come
up with all that information earlier so
you got 23 more hours so I am going to
um
conclude the hearing on House Bill
213 and put the exec of it in
abeyance Waiting For What our committee
researcher comes up with and with
that uh we actually have can you believe
it 9 minutes I cannot open the hearing
and
e
before we get to the next bill I am
going to open a an exec session briefly
on House Bill uh 213 is
it is that what we
doing and the purpose of the exec
session is not to EXA the bill per se
but to
request the the budget people to prepare
a fiscal note this is what we found them
saying to us to representative Greg's
question about uh gee if we pass the
bill and doesn't have a fiscal note
what's going to happen so the motion
before us is does this committee
wish the budget office whatever it is to
prepare a fiscal note for
us and I will move that as the chair um
representative Greg will second that any
discussion on it this does not commit us
to the bill it just means we can then go
it that is the
motion just so it's on the record I'll
go and say that um the reason we're
doing this is because we learned last
time the courts do not make forms so we
understand they're going to have to get
an outside resource and there will be a
cost for this so we're just trying to be
as responsible as we can with this bill
with the knowledge we have that was a
good catch on this representative so
would the clerk please call the role on
the motion to ask uh for a fiscal
note on the motion to ask for a fiscal
note for HB
2113 Mr chairman yes
representative deimon yes representative
rice representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
sidel
yes representative love yes
representative coren yes representative
marel yes representative patrino yes
representative
Gman is absent representative LC is
absent representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes
representative georgees yes
representative Malone
yes
unanimously 14 zip yes OTP oot it's an
exact OTP I don't know how to put that I
don't either I don't either that's why I
just put it on a posted and I was to put
yeah fiscal request it's just yeah but
we got I don't think it goes on a green
sheet but I think it's good to go to the
budget people so call call Paul y sure
and now open the hearing on House Bill
243 with
representative chairman of I never get
this right Fish game in Marine sources
resource I'm getting closer each time
and it's House Bill 243 an act relative
to the penalty for false reports of
suspected abuse and neglect made to the
division for children youth and families
and just before the uh break we counted
67 in favor and four opposed online and
I'm sure the numbers are continuing to
to commend as we speak chairman Spain
thank you present your bill please thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
uh again this will look familiar this is
the same exact bill that was passed
through the house three times last term
and I'm sure you're wondering how could
you do it three times in one term well
especially with an evenly divided house
where we were basically 50/50 it's a
very bipartisan concern that people have
with the weaponizing of the system uh
there are 30 or so states that this is
currently already a law there's a
penalty in place when you do a false
report ours is a little bit higher bar
because we want to make sure we we don't
uh just automatically start
uh scaring people from making reports so
you have to do the way this bill is
written it's uh you have to have made
the complaint knowingly false with
intent to harm which is very hard to
prove so it wouldn't happen to any
firsttime reporter it would only happen
to somebody who they could build up a
pattern of abuse against the system with
and uh because of this committee's
request last term we added a section
into um in fact I believe it was the
chairman who asked asked for this to be
to be added in uh that the there was a a
section for professional mandatory
reporters who fail to make a report
because we realize there's nothing in
statute to put a penalty on somebody who
is a professional reporter uh now you're
all mandatory reporters everyone is so
we wanted to make sure we made a
distinction that they're professional
mandatory reporters those who are in the
profession and trained and if they fail
to make a report they also could get a
penalty so the way this passed through
the house three times last term was that
I passed it through in the very first
year and it became the house position
although the Senate retained it um when
I introduced it in the second year
exactly as it was the same it was again
um tabled by the Senate and so then when
an amendment came over from the Senate
from the chairman of the committee over
there I put it on that amend I put it as
an amendment on that and we passed it
through the house as an amendment to
that bill that came over from the Senate
and they killed that one too so we're
back here again uh after passing this
through the house with with Democrat and
Republican support and we're trying to
do it again hopefully we can get it
through the Senate this time and
hopefully we'll get it through the house
first yet again um I'll take any
questions if anyone has them but
everyone who was here in the committee
last term knows this one inside out and
I I think you probably already
know representative Greg um thank you Mr
chairman and this is kind of a question
but I think it might be helpful if you
go over it again just because at least
half of our I think about half our
committee is new so I think it would be
helpful for you if that is the wish of
the
committee so it does not prohibit
Anonymous reporting but it
encourages non-anonymous reports um
you'll see this new language that says
reports made to the department may
include the name address or phone number
of the person or person's making the
report of a suspected abuse or neglect
of a child under this chapter says they
may they don't have to but the
department themselves said they they
prefer if they have a name so they can
follow up um so they liked that and this
language was actually uh drafted by the
prior director of uh DCF and myself uh
before he left and we have a new one now
um the department may also inform the
complainant that should the complaint be
made maliciously or with intent to harm
the complainant may be subject to
criminal and civil penalties this is an
option
but I was told by the director of that
department that he would love to be able
to have his employees be able to give
that sort of verbal prodding if they
know it's the same person calling yet
again because they said there's very few
of the people who take the calls and
they tend to get to know a voice or a
number and they might be able to stop
things right there if they can give this
warning so that's in there as well at
the um as a May doesn't have to be done
but at the discretion of the person
taking the call it can be be uh given as
a
warning um there's a section new section
two under the immunity that says nothing
in this section shall provide civil or
criminal immunity for a professional
mandatory reporter who knowingly fails
to make a report of suspected abuse or
neglect under RSA 169 C colon 29 or for
a person who knowingly files a false
report of abuse or neglect with malice
or the intent to harm under RSA 169c 31a
that's the section that basically
has the penalty for the false report but
also uh at the prodding of this
committee uh puts a penalty in for those
people who fail to report so they can be
held accountable um these would be
professional people such as it
specifically says yeah only the
professionals if they fail to report
professional mandatory
reporter um but the other bit for making
a false report as
anyone and that's it that's the
extent the um penalties are already in
different rsas and I assume that the the
reference to those was one of those
things that the Senate wanted because
that way it was not something that we
were introducing a new penalty if the
penalty gets updated and the other one
we're still referencing that one and
it's done in one place for a cleaner
bill I
don't originally my original language
many years ago said it was a misdemeanor
that's now referencing other areas where
it's a misdemeanor still so it's still a
misdemeanor are you open the questions I
am open to questions one question I
would have I love to I love to see what
other states do but then I like to go
into a little bit of detail and if a
bill sounds kind of conservative what do
liberal states do and vice versa just to
see if maybe this isn't a conservative
or a liberal thing states of all kinds
and shades of colors um are in on it or
in some way or other um I know that
Massachusetts in New York has some
pretty in California okay it has some
pretty strict penalties on this in in
your knowledge has this led to a
significant diminution of complaints and
other words people are scared off no and
I think if you asked the uh the
divisions in both all three of those
States uh if they are getting plenty of
reports they would agree that they have
more than they can
handle but the false ones are not being
done as proliferant because they can
actually penalize people uh one of the
things that I find egregious that this I
will we can hopefully fix by passing
this is that if I went out right now and
pulled a fire alarm for no reason I
could get charged with something if I
went and made a false police
report I could get charged with
something but the way our law is written
right now if my neighbor decides to have
his dog poop in my front yard and I
didn't like it I could call up and
report him as abusing his kids and
there's nothing that can be done even if
they know it's me who did it in fact
even if I call up every week and report
him for abusing his kids there's nothing
they can do and dcyf is under an
obligation to investigate every claim
they get and that takes away the
resources from other cases where they
really should be spending their time
real cases of abuse and instead they're
chasing down dead ends from family
members one of the things that was told
to me by the the other director of dcyf
who's who's now left he said that one of
the biggest problems they had was once
the opioid epidemic got really big and
they were losing parents to
incarceration or overdoses and the
children were being placed with
grandparents they found a surge in the
number of complaints they were trying to
handle because this grandparent thought
they should have custody and if they
made complaints about that grandparent
then they could get the custody of the
kids and they were not true complaints
there was no real danger to the children
but they were being the system was being
weaponized because they realized there's
nothing they can do if I make those
complaints it's also weaponized in the
case of divorce a
lot any questions representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and um thank you
representative um so as I don't know if
everybody knows but as a lot of people
know I actually work worked for child
protective services in New York for many
years where they have a similar law um
but you're not allowed to report
anonymously in New York and um frankly a
lot of the malicious reporting that we
got when I worked there was in the cases
of um domestic violence or an
acrimonious divorce um I never once saw
in all the years um anybody get
prosecuted for this uh which I think
I've said before my question is about um
how this bill will address the people
who are going to continue to call
anonymously to report their ex or their
neighbor or the person that they're
angry at um because I think right now um
anybody can do that anonymously the bill
doesn't change the ability to do it
anonymously and the people up at the
state um have a lot of training on how
to identify whether or not something
seems like it's um a legitimate
complaint versus not like they ask a lot
of questions and they have decision
trees um and if we learned this morning
that they screen out a good percentage
of the calls that come in already
because they don't meet the criteria so
I guess my question is how do you see
this spill
impacting like the the anonymous
situation and also you know the
maliciousness that you're alleging
happen thank you for the question
representative um you know if it was up
to me I would love to remove the
anonymous uh ability to the ability to
make an anonymous complaint as well but
um um I was told by the department and
people who worked there that that they
had concerns about that and so in an
effort to try to get something done to
get at least some amount of
accountability to prevent those that
where where the person was known and I
there's an example I could give you from
um one of the people who called me and I
get I get more and more calls every year
every year that this bill is going
forward and especially when it hits the
papers as a person from the the Press
here today that was talking about it um
I get more and more complaints and and
calls from people that I don't even
represent in my district but they heard
about the bill and they want to tell me
their story so there's a woman in um
another part of the state and I won't
say the area but um mother of four two
sets of twins going through a divorce
that was taking 5 years and was getting
calls once a month or so from the
girlfriend of the ex-husband the new
girlfriend of the ex-husband in an
effort to try to change the way that the
divorce outcome would happen
um she had to basically talk to them
about the complaint every single month
once a month and it caused stress in the
family it caused stress to her they knew
who it was calling she didn't do it
anonymously but there was nothing they
could do and um those false reports were
made exactly fitting what we would call
maliciously with intent to harm um
so I've seen many of these and this
would at least handle some level of it
and whether in the future somebody
decides to remove all of the anonymous
part
too that's fine in my opinion you
shouldn't be able to make such an
egregious complaint anonymously um but
that's not what we're here for today
okay
quick followup representative Rond thank
you Mr chairman my other question was
about um the definition of a
professional mandatory reporter is that
term defined anywhere else in statute um
because I'm curious if this impacts
someone who has a professional job who
is reporting as a citizen or only if
they're reporting in their professional
capacity and how um the law might
interpret this like if I if if we have a
Doctor Who's shopping at Walmart and he
sees you know a kid being you know
violently shaken or abused at Walmart is
he now a professional mandated reporter
or is he a citizen who happens to have a
job that professionally he would also
have to report good question I do not
know I trusted OS to take the language
that the chair gave me as he himself as
a professional mandatory reporter um and
for them to craft around it but it might
be something good to look into to find
out if it's defined somewhere but also
keep in mind the professional mandatory
reporter part is only a penalty if they
fail fa to report under the statute that
says that they are a mandatory reporter
the the regular false reports is
everybody so so if the professional
mandatory
reporter saw somebody in the supermarket
and walked by I can't see how they'd be
under the
obligation as their job and I don't
think that would apply but it's a
question for OS well yeah I guess that's
my question because if if if they're
professionally in their job if they saw
in their waiting room they would have to
call but if they're at Walmart and they
see it and they don't call are they
going to be subject to the same kind of
penalties since we are all mandated
reporters I I imagine that uh first
you'd have to figure out who was going
to know that he was a doctor in Walmart
that didn't report but I don't know
newshire we all know each other but but
in in any case it's a very good question
and I I would um certainly go and ask uh
further questions if you'd like me to uh
and get an answer back for the committee
I might suggest or you could have your
researcher do it well I might suggest
representative that um uh you you chase
this one down also while you're going to
be making an amendment I'm not going to
exec this for a bit
um the 500 section of
um yeah I'm totally blanking what's that
pink book that I've read so many times
oh Rules of Evidence the 500 section uh
deals with privilege communication so if
if a mandatory reporter Witnesses
something in certain professional
capacities that person can't report so
it wouldn't be a bad idea while you're
fleshing out what a professional
mandatory reporter who knowingly fails
is you also take a look at the
exceptions to that I would hate to get
into a legal Crossfire between the 500
section which is um lawyer client uh
Prest penitent which is 505 and 502 I
think is lawyer and client and 503 is
counselor and doctor and so on so in
other words while you're up might be
good to really polish this one up
absolutely representative rice thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um so I kind of have two
questions go with the first one one
first first um so I'm concerned about
the language it says the department May
inform the complainant that should the
um complaint be made maliciously or with
intent to harm the complaint it may be
subject to criminal and civil civil
penalties um I have concerns that
they're going to pick and choose who
they're going to tell this to because it
says may right they should be be doing
this if they're under penalty of my
trouble thank you thank you
representative for the question my um my
original draft of that said they shall
and the director of the dcyf department
said he didn't really want his people to
have to say that to everyone they he
wanted to let them make the choice under
their own discretion because they had so
few people taking the calls that they
got to know certain people who did it
often and they wanted to be able to give
that warning to those people that they
knew was the same person calling yet
again and so that was actually a request
from the Department that that changed
from a sh to a May thank
you and under that the fact that it uses
the word sub object to still gives
discretionary power in other words
you're vulnerable to it doesn't mean
you're going to get it so the may just
heightens I think the their their point
on this question two is there anything
in the law that
prohibits someone
from taking civil action against someone
for filing false reports because I know
that you have it in here is is there
anything that prohibits them from doing
that without this being in
the I don't know that it's specifically
prohibited but uh I know that in the
case when I had a false accusation made
against me many years ago uh for
political reasons um the person did it
anonymously and we weren't able to chase
it down if they were
prosecuted they would be able to then
have that extra evidence for the civil
case um so I don't know if there's
anything that prohibits that but I know
it can be expensive to defend yourself
against a false claim as well I know I
dropped personally $4,000 on on a false
claim U before it was considered
unfounded after two weeks of telling
them no you're not coming in the house
but we can meet at the attorney's
office so thank you anyone else on the
committee question for the witness
seeing none thank you thank you thank
you for your testimony thank you for the
committee chair recognizes Susan larabe
from
DCF good afternoon Mr chair chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Susan larby I am general counsel and
legislative liaison for the division for
children youth and families I'm here
basically to answer any questions you
may have about this bill I recognize and
we all recognize as part of
dcyf that you all have worked very hard
on this bill especially the
representative sponsoring the bill and
working with former director ribson on
this uh so we take no position as to the
bill itself we absolutely recognize the
need to balance that civil and criminal
immunity for those who are in good faith
seeing something saying something that
no in tell campaign that we've all
worked on over the years with
stakeholders see something say something
when you have good faith to believe that
a child has been abused or neglected
that we all have to watch out for our
children and to balance that with those
who weaponize that reporting so of
course we recognize that there is a a
balance to that what I was going to
testify to
has already been addressed the bill that
we received to do a fiscal note on still
had the language shell that the
department shall inform the caller that
they could be held to civil or criminal
liability and that was what we took
issue with in the bill because when
we're talking with the
caller it is so important for the
central intake worker the social worker
to get as much information from that
caller as possible about the fact
how they know why they know that this
children this child could have been
abused or neglected and that also
includes working with that caller to
feel comfortable to give them their name
their contact
information because not only is the
caller talking to that witness later on
if that gets screened in and referred
for an investigation to an assessment
worker that assessment worker is going
to want to call and talk with that work
worker uh talk with that caller and get
more information do a full interview
with that caller and if we were to tell
them hey by the way just so you know and
then regurgitate what it says here that
you can be uh if you made this call with
Mali malicious intent or with intent to
harm you may be subject to criminal or
civil liabilities we're afraid that it
would have unint the opposite unintended
results they would immediately hang up
and not be cooperative with with the um
uh experience that's so important that
they give us that information and
typically they do out of the 27,000
reports to Central intake in this fiscal
year of 2024 only just over a thousand
were uh Anonymous
1,23 and I think again that comes to
having that conversation with the caller
hey hey tell us about this how do you
know this why do you know this and to
tell them that they could be held
liable we think would have the
unintended results so I'm happy to we're
happy to see that the shell has been
replaced with
may as a followup uh to your question
about is there a definition a
professional reporter well it's a little
bit complicated because the law itself
in 169
c29 does give the laundry list of those
professions that typically have the
confidential privileged attached to
their
work and honestly I think that's why
people forget that very last sentence
because it go through any physician
surgeon County Medical Examiner
psychiatrist resident intern dentist
social worker daycare worker on and on
and then the very last sentence says or
any other person having reason to
suspect that a child has been abused or
neglected shell report so that laundry
list uh
is what we would consider the
professional
reporter and if there's any other
questions you may have for me I'm happy
questions representative sidel welcome
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I just I uh could you
repeat the r could you be a little
closer to the mic please are you able to
repeat the RSA that you were referring
to with the laundry list please yes so
the mandatory reporting statute is our
29 does that have and I'm not going to
run back to get it but um does that have
any carve out for uh privileg
assumed no um because again it's it's
implied that this is because these
professions have that profession
professional confidentiality attached
with their their licensing um I know
Healthcare has it specifically in their
one of their statues referring to Health
Care um I don't have that in front of
me okay thank you uh representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you um for coming to talk to us
can you tell us a little bit about the
um people who work up at Central intake
are they like dispatch officers like
when you call to report a car accident
or a crime or are they more social
workers who have an interview process
with the person calling sure uh during
the day and I believe the hours are 8 to
5:30 it is staffed by a cpsw staff so
Child Protection social worker somebody
typically who is not hired to be Central
intake they have been hired to be an
assistant worker a field work and they
have transferred positions and are now a
central intake worker however after
hours because the mandatory hotline is
open 247 during after hours including
weekends and holidays it is staffed by
more of a what we would call a
traditional dispatcher uh we have a
contract with a residential facility in
Massachusetts a home for little
Wanderers that has a we have a contract
else thank you counselor thank you thank
testimony and good
penmanship that good penmanship is that
good really good very good yeah yeah
we can wave the badge if you help you
you gotta one try too you know what else
do
Bingo good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the child and family law
committee my name is Emily Lawrence and
I'm the advocacy director with Waypoint
um just to give you a little background
on Waypoint we are an a Statewide agency
that provides services for Children and
Families those Services include um
court-ordered services for families that
are involved in dcyf the division for
children youth and families so those
could be inhome Services as well as
community- based voluntary services for
families that are at risk of involvement
with the the division for children youth
and families um we also do supervised
visitation um and family
reunification and permanency among other
things that relate to this Bill I'm here
today to testify in opposition to this
bill and I just want to share I outlined
my concerns and my written testimony so
I just want to share a couple of points
of concern our main concern is that the
bill will have a chilling effect on
reporters I want to be clear that we do
understand concerns about false
reporting um I in my prior role had
heard those concerns and I don't want to
dismiss them but I think for us the
importance is the safety of the child
and so I'm worried that the that the
average person may already be reluctant
to report because they may not want to
interfere or disrupt a family's life
they may not be intimidated by the
reporting process and so they may not
appreciate or even read the statute to
know that they would have to do it they
would have to knowingly and with
malicious intent file a false report so
I'm worrying that this will in further
decrease reports for abuse and neglect I
think there are also concerns when there
are situations of domestic violence
where um the almost what people are
worried about happening right now for
the purpose of the bill could happen in
the flip in that someone could weaponize
this bill against a victim saying well
if you're going to report this I'm going
to say you did it knowingly and Mal with
malicious intent and so victims may be
reluctant to report a legitimate abuse
that is
happening um so those are our primary
concerns I will note and this has
already been discussed that there is
some concern with the language of um
that you've already discussed about
professional mandated reporter I think
that there could be some if if the
legislature is inclined to pass the
statute there should be some clarity
introduced into that and perhaps even
just referring back to the um
professions that are enumerated in 169
c29 would be helpful so that people
people are given notice um if they are
considered a professional mandated
reporter um again if the legislature is
inclined to pass this law we would also
uh suggest that there are alternatives
to the immediate op option of a
misdemeanor um several other states and
I believe Mr chairman had mentioned
Massachusetts earlier have different
approaches Massachusetts and I put all
of these in my written testimony if you
want to see has a graduated approach so
the first two calls would be um for
fines and then the the third call would
be for a criminal penalty um Maine
simply exempts people from civil and
Criminal immunity and then Connecticut
gives the judge the option so the judge
can choose whether it is um a civil
penalty with a fine or whether it's a
criminal penalty so I would argue that
those are um a bit less daunting for
people so uh again if people are
reluctant to call then maybe that would
make them less reluctant if they weren't
worried that right off the bat it could
potentially be a
misdemeanor so those our concerns and
I'm happy to take any questions at any
time thank you very
much I'm H how would you
compare the statement that was made
earlier that states with
penalties have not seen a diminution of
calling with with your statement you are
speculating that it would cause a
shortfall but it seems that the evidence
is that it's
not um I would agreed that I don't have
data to show that that actually happens
um it it doesn't mean it doesn't it's
just that I'm not sure that states have
we did look for that data and we were
not able to find any I think From
waypoint's perspective it really is
about protecting children and so that
would that is our primary concern that
we would not want one child to go abused
or neglected because someone was leery
of
reporting would it be abuse of a
child if frivolous complaints were
regularly made against the house that
child lives in the parents in particular
wouldn't that traumatize the child that
there are all these investigations going
on wouldn't that hurt I think if you
have multiple repeated investigations
possibly but I also think that DCF um
you've heard that they ask a number of
questions they are Adept and experts at
screening people in or screening people
out um so I know that a lot of those
calls are caught right from the
get-go
would um the reference to RSA 169 c29
which defines as we heard professionals
be adequately close to the statement
professional mandatory reporter because
it's in the same sentence would would
that be close enough to Define uh who a
professional you mean referring to those
Professionals in there yeah you said
that a vague term but it's defined in
the same sentence by shooting us to a
oursa reference oh it is to it page page
I missed it I missed it the first couple
of times reading it through myself but
it's in page two Roman 2 um bold italic
nothing in this section shall and then
it goes on professional mandatory
reporter under RSA 169 c29 would that
satisfy the concerns you raise that does
there you may want to ALS uh it's also
one um and so I guess you it could
arguably be implied since 169 c29 that's
on line 24 of page 1 it's also
referenced there I I would still argue
it could just be clearer for people but
questions no seeing none thank you thank
you oh sorry representative love good
morning thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question um wouldn't the fact that we
have
uh uh Anonymous reporting nullify a lot
of your fears uh it seems like you're
afraid that that people won't report but
they can still anonymously report uh it
just doesn't add up to me certainly
people could anonymously report I'm not
sure everyone knows that either um so
just like I don't think people would
read the statute to know about the
possible pen penalty for malicious um
false reporting I'm not sure they would
know that they could anonymously report
a lot of people don't know that until
they call in and I and I could be I
don't want to over speak for the
department but I'm sure the department
would prefer that people don't
anonymously report so they likely might
ask for their name and people may not
know that they don't have to give
you thank you for your testimony thank
you very much chair
recognizes the uh senior clerk Jody
Nelson
but only after she knocks you
out that's why we have spares and
it thank you Mr chairman and thank you
to the committee for uh listening to me
for a couple minutes this should not
take long uh one thing that I wanted to
have us think about
is um the impact that some false
reporting has on daycares um in my
discussions with some people about this
bill um there are daycares that do have
false complaints reported against them
and there are definitely uh
repercussions for the daycare as well as
the families um who attend daycare um
long time ago about 20 years ago my
daughter was about three and we had a
wonderful situation with an at home
daycare person who also um had
previously watched um older cousins of
my daughters who had a very trust
trusting and loving relationship with
this person and I received a phone call
from Massachusetts DCF and that person
said hello Mrs Nelson I need to talk to
you
about the daycare provider um we've had
a report of child
abuse against her and I need to get some
details from you and I said well she
um she has older children and her
youngest is a senen her in high school
and I've only ever witnessed her being a
wonderful mother she loves her kids so
much and he said he interrupted me he
said no Mrs Nelson I need to talk to you
about a report that's been filed that
has claimed she's been abusing your
child so um to make a long story short
um the the report was closed it was
unfounded however myself and six other
families had to immediately find
alternate Child Care during the course
of the investigation that was
understandably closed quickly and I
appreciated that I had at the time a
very understanding employer so taking
three days off on an emergency basis and
working from home was something that I
would be able to do but I also know that
some of the other parents were concerned
about losing their jobs so I just wanted
to um you know give that brief little
story about myself and uh let you know
that it's not only um family members uh
weaponizing uh you know the system to
punish or get other family members in
trouble or you know new girlfriends or
new boyfriends it it can also affect uh
daycare situations as
questions thank you representative you
chair recognizes attorney Lisa masio
good afternoon chairman Pearson and
committee members I am attorney Lisa
massio I am the associate child advocate
from the State Office of the New
Hampshire Office of the child advocate I
am our legislative and policy director
ctor um while all that paper is getting
passed around I'm going to give you our
very brief elevator speech um we didn't
um get to present this morning chairman
Pearson has invited us to come at some
other time we are a state agency a very
very small one we are independent um
administratively attached to das and we
are mandated as oversight to all child
serving executive branch agencies we
were created in 2017 in response to some
tragic child deaths in the state our
purview was then expanded in 2020 so now
we cover All State agencies that impact
children to include dcyf Child
Protection Juvenile Justice um bcbh all
of whom you heard from this morning as
well as all contracted providers such as
Waypoint residential
facilities um and all service providers
so we uh do both legislative work
systemic work as well as we have a
couple of ombudsmen who actually do case
specific specific work they take calls
about specific cases um of concern
involving children in the state either
not receiving services or not receiving
appropriate services so we look forward
to uh coming and talking to you more
soon as for right now um we are here to
oppose HB 243 as currently written
although it sounds like there might have
already been changes since the published
one that I last saw um this is similar
to Prior legislation we have actually
testified before you before over the
last couple of years um essentially the
office of child advocate was created to
give a voice uh to the best interest of
children and advocate for children
particularly those involved with state
agencies like Child Protection in order
to avoid um future child deaths uh
issues like the harmony mcgomery case
I'm sure you all know the high-profile
ones but there's thousands of children
that are affected by the system every
day at a much lower level that doesn't
make the news so just generally uh we
oppose any legislation that would limit
reporting of suspect suspected child
abuse to the division or as um attorney
Lawrence mentioned a chilling effect on
reporting um when it said shall inform
people that they could be reported that
could have a chilling effect on someone
who's calling as an attorney I would
also say if it's May you now have a
disperate impact or a potential like
equal application problem of you're
picking and choosing who you tell so if
someone gets penalties and they're like
well no one ever told me that's also a
problem um we would uh be concerned
about the chilling effect um as others
have mentioned um we do still allow
Anonymous reporting here we are in favor
of that in order to allow everyone to
make a report even if they're not
comfortable sharing their name however I
believe attorney larab be mentioned most
people do share their names and that is
important because the dcyf assessment
worker does follow up and get some
really important information so anyone
who is told we may use your name to uh
hold you criminally liable May withhold
their name frankly I I believe
representative Raymond al already
mentioned if you're allowed to be
anonymous and you're making a malicious
or false report the chances are you're
going to stay Anonymous you're not going
to give your name anyway so just as a
practical matter the impact of this law
might not be that great as folks who are
planning on giving false information
probably would already not give their
name um in
addition people trying to make a good
faith report may be inhibited um with
that warning or even if they just heard
about this law um as a further matter
that hasn't been mentioned yet the uh
dcyf Central intake workers as mentioned
by attorney larab B are social workers
their jobs are to determine if a child
has been abused or neglected uh and to
determine Central intake specific
whether the facts being told to them
rise to the level of even being screened
in um last session the DCF director
testified that this bill wasn't
necessary false reporting really wasn't
an issue that dcyf is really doing a
fine job of screening out reports that
don't rise the level if even if they are
investigated if the facts are not
ascertained to rise to a statutory level
for the definitions of abuse neglect
they're unfounded now unfounded doesn't
mean false
but someone who's calling who isn't sure
if it's abuse or neglect certainly might
feel well if I'm wrong am I going to be
prosecuted so again this use of the word
false a doesn't mean the person knowing
giving the information believes it to be
untrue but also an unfounded report does
not mean it's false it means that it
didn't rise to the statutory level so I
think constructionwise there's a lot of
terms in here that are just problematic
and would be incredibly difficult to
enforce and also who's going to enforce
this it is not dcf's job to determine
the intent of the person calling they're
not trying to determine if the
information is malicious if it's given
knowingly falsely their job is to
protect kids and we want them to remain
laser focused on that task to determine
if this child is in danger not to
determine if this adult calling in has a
bad intent knows something's false is
reckless or or whatever other standard
you want to put in there that's simply
not their job so whose job is it who's
going to be determining if this is false
if this is malicious um a similar issue
exists with the penalties against a
professional reporter which um I don't
believe that 169 c29 defines
professional reporter it has a laundry
list of
professions so that's another issue but
regardless um for a professional of any
sort to be held to a
standard regarding a failure to report
something it's it's like proving a
negative who who's going to go out there
and find these people that allegedly
failed to report something that they may
have known um it's it's not really a
standard that can be proven I'm not sure
who would be doing that um and it really
having these civil and criminal
penalties opens the door to I believe
someone already said sort of the flip
side of threats of I'm going to now go
Civ sue you for maliciously reporting me
because we're having a neighbor dispute
or we're having a very contentious
divorce or this is a domestic violence
situation I think in particular the
Civil penalties really opens the door to
a lot of unnecessary and malicious
litigation and again it's incredibly
difficult to improve to prove what
intent somebody made a phone call with
um so for all those reasons and again
this anyone that sat here last year
probably heard me say the same thing on
HB 1111 um the the wording of this bill
is problematic I know you've discussed a
couple other states um you know
mechanisms for this and perhaps looking
at those might be more helpful but
generally the office of child advocate
does not support putting constraints
around reporting our reporting law is
purposely very Broad and very sweeping
in order to get the most number of
reports to protect children because we
can tell you the office of the child
Advocates re uh receives what something
called um critical incident reports
which are reports of child deaths parent
deaths severe um cases of abuse and
neglect and typically those um cirs that
we receive there are numerous sometimes
up to two dozen screened out reports for
those families numerous investigations
that were unfounded
and then in fact in the end the child is
Gravely injured or dead um so again our
process is not perfect but we already
see instances where kids are falling
through the gaps and bad things are
happening we would hate to see any
further constraints on people feeling
like they can make calls should make
calls we do have a very extensive know
and tell training for teachers and other
um professional reporters which is not
defined um that really encourages people
if your gut is telling you something's
going on your job is to call dcf's job
is to investigate and determine not your
job that's not your job normal citizens
even professional reporters we have
trained professionals who generally do a
very good job and that's their job so
let dcyf do their job once they get that
call to screen it in or investigate it
um don't put that burden on the general
questions seeing none seeing
one representative cidel thank you Mr
chairman I guess you're the one this
year that I'm going to miss the hand of
was
representative before I think you've
practiced looking at me a lot now I did
a lot muscle memory yeah that's what it
is you need to wear brighter
colors than
you thank you for taking my question um
one of the comments you recently made
was there's still kids falling through
the gaps and I'm what I'm hearing a lot
in in present people that are presenting
against this bill is the concern for the
reporter more than the concern for the
child so my my concern is if we're
allowing all these people to maliciously
report without knowing and and whoever
is going to be determining whether it's
malicious or not there are actual cases
going on kid children that are being
abused and they can't be followed
because we're following all these false
reports that we have no penalty on so
could you explain how we can minimize
the false reports without having
something in
legislation thank you I I appreciate
your question you're right behind
the um so again I am not sure that there
are a great number of false reports
testimony last year from the DCF
director was that there aren't a lot of
false reports they don't feel like it's
an issue um I certainly wouldn't testify
to whether or not there are malicious
reports or how many I believe the
current screening process screens out at
least this was a testimony of the dcyf
director last year and we we don't hear
otherwise that um and again I won't say
what's false because it might not be
correct but that doesn't mean the person
calling is making a false report they
have a
concern they should call their concern
into the professional to assess there
are many many reports that are screened
out which means it never even makes it
to an assessment many
reports once a report makes it to an
assessment that's where it's being
determined whether it's founded or
unfounded but again a lot of the cases
most serious cases we see there are
dozens of screened out reports so
nothing ever happened that family was
never even
notified that there was a a call um so
from our experience at the OCA that's
not a problem we are hearing about it
from the testimony last year it didn't
seem like it was a big issue that the
the division was concerned about there
Central intake is doing their job to
screen in or out reports appropriately
and then conduct investigations and
again the OCA really is most concerned
about the kids because we would rather
see
too many reports made that maybe are
screened out but one more investigation
that protects a child that may have been
engraved danger is really enough for us
to to feel that it's important for that
made representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you attorney masio
one of the things that you said about um
what happens if if dcyf thinks it's a
malicious report me think of a question
about what happens when they think that
and so I I almost think it's a question
for DCF and not necessarily you but my
question is if the worker whether it's
at Central intake or you know out on the
on the ground thinks that someone has
made a false report in order to harm
someone else what do they do with that
information if this bill is
passed my friend Susan laraby may want
to come join me so um sorry Mr chairman
I didn't think of it until she said that
and then okay now well and I can tell
you I was a dcyf attorney for several
years I was also a parent side attorney
I was also a private family law attorney
handling many of those terribly
contentious divorces I think attorney
larby said earlier uh they do become
familiar with these sort of frequent
flyers of contentious divorce cases um
where calls are being made on each other
and often I can tell you the division
will be subpoena into some of those
divorce cases to testify about because
often there's reports flying back and
forth um so I I will defer to to many of
those myself yes so I mean there are
other mechanisms as well where like in a
highly contentious divorce case which is
an INF Family Division but under 461a
not 169c one or the other parent will
actually subpoena dcy have to come
testify about how terrible the other
parent is so those are handled in
multiple Arenas but I will defer to
Susan if she has some data thank thank
you addressing the first question so it
has always been our belief that 169
c39 covers both false reporting and
failure to report when it says anyone
who knowingly violates any section of
169c is guilty of a misdemeanor and
again putting on my prior hat as a
prosecutor and you had asked uh attorney
masot to asked well how does that happen
that the report happens all the time
especially in my old world where kiddo
would be interviewed at the Child
Advocacy Center and would say oh I
disclosed this last year to my teacher
and my teacher never well we learned the
teacher never reported or something like
that that would lead to a prosecution of
failure to report and absolutely we are
not criminal prosecutors at dcyf and in
fact we we are busy enough uh
investigating abuse and neglect of
kiddos if we believed that there was a
knowingly false report made to DCF we
would refer that to law enforcement it's
law enforcement and prosecutors who are
Prosecuting criminal offenses not
DCF once more yes yeah follow up so that
follow is that the current practice the
current practice is that if at a child
advocacy at a yeah Child Advocacy Center
interview or even a worker who's gotten
seven reports and they're all nothing
is the current practice that they would
bring it to their supervisor and the
supervisor would contact the police or
it just they just say too
bad if we ever believe that there is a
crime that has been committed whether it
be failure to report or or a false
report to law enforcement yes we would
refer that to law enforcement and
majority of our cases are involv a joint
investigation right so anytime that we
believe that a child has not only been a
victim of abuse and neglect
also could be a victim of a crime we
report that to law enforcement and we do
what's called a joint investigation with
law enforcement so for instance at a CAC
for the most part I don't know the
percentages but majority of our cases
the dcyf worker the law enforcement and
the prosecutor are all at the table of
that CAC interview hearing the
information at the same
time last follow one more so if this
were Bill were to pass with some of the
changes that the chairman has suggested
would it change the practice in the
offices at
all it would not change current practice
we are we are currently uh asking for
information that first part that says we
may uh gather information about the
personal identifiable information from
the reporter we're already getting that
we I explained earlier how helpful and
how needed is to have that information
from the caller and then again if we
believe that 16 9 c39 has been violated
we would we would refer that to law
enforcement if they haven't already
investigation thank you okay thank you
councilors uh chair would like to
recognize Katherine
Shay thank you we look forward to coming
to tell you more about the
day right thank you Mr chairman thank
you committee for hearing me today
Katherine Shay gtown mother of two sets
of teenage twins
now happy to say I've
survived driving they're two years apart
so and I think you heard two sets of
twins earlier so thanks for hearing me
today I'll keep it short because I have
to get to the DMV for my license and why
am I here today good question because
it's my birthday so
um I feel this is so important to be
here and I don't just represent myself
when I I come here to conquer I try to
come as a volunteer to represent other
people that can't be here other divorced
parents other uh parents of special
needs kids like myself I have three
they're on the
Spectrum and as a profession I do
process re-engineering uh I'm a
specialist in it I'm a IT program
manager this is my thing but today I
don't want to be here about process
because we could go on all day long
about process and there's holes in it
and there's you know needs better
filtering that's kind of a separate
topic you know like whatever their
process needs to change to be to be
better is also something good to think
about but for today I really want to
talk about the Crux of this which is
dishonesty and when I was a kid growing
up we were taught not to lie we were
taught there were consequences for lying
we were taught that if you told a lie
you're going to tell another lie and
another lie to cover it up and there are
real consequences for those things I
heard somebody said earlier
unfortunately um you know whose job is
it somebody said unfounded does not mean
false well if it's unfounded and
someone's out overtly lying you know so
where's the repercussions for that
person and it's not just one person
we're talking about multiple people so
in the case of my family the nightmare
began 10 years ago and I'm brittle and
getting old because of all of these
things that happened to our family
literally affected me physically
mentally in every possible way was
extremely expensive requiring me to hire
a second lawyer during a six-year
Marathon family law divorce with a
crappy gal and I had to pay $300 more an
hour out of pocket for someone else just
to protect our family and there was no
going to the police the police weren't
going to do anything there's no law in
place about this if you file a false a
police report you're going to hear from
the police about that so this
perpetrator and I'm happy to send you a
diagram that I've testified on year
after year after year about
this engineered 12 to 20 people to all
maliciously attack right of the gates
thinking that would give them an upper
hand in a divorce and that had such a
ripple through effect it turned you know
the reputation upside down even if it's
unfounded the damage is done right and
we heard unfounded doesn't mean false so
what do you think that puts in the minds
of people around you co-workers
neighbors school officials when you're
trying to advocate for your kids to have
an IEP and just to get a free and
appropriate education and so somebody
thinks it's funny or cool to get back at
you and call something in false or to
actually collude with your ex-husband
and get in on it together 12 to 20
people all made false complaints many of
them did know you could do anonymously
and they chose to do that in many cases
hiding behind a therapist even in one
case where it was a girlfriend's two she
called her two daughters called the
therapist called and they get layers of
protection meanwhile I'm out there in
the open exposed working my you know
tail off trying to keep my household
going keep my kids educated fed and
everybody happy and the cost of that
almost cost my son a very serious
medical condition where we were on the
verge of needing expert help meanwhile
these are coming in and I'm in a
hospital room with a kid with a brain
condition can you imagine how that feels
to somebody the Injustice can never be
made right it's a lot like if you ever
read The Scarlet Letter and you walk
around you remember Hester pran in the
story of the Scarlet lad she had that
emblazoned on her
permanently and so this is not about
process this is not about civil remedy
this is we have a loophole and that
loophole is causing people to be really
harmed and I'm a caseing in point about
that I'm literally falling apart now I
have medical issues and all kinds of
stuff it's because I couldn't take care
of myself because I had to pay for
lawyers meanwhile that person walks
scot-free and can still think they can
do that and there was no stopping this
person there was no filter up front all
of them were sent right through and
every time actually at the end they
actually did say you know Mr I'm not
going to say the name we're starting to
catch on a little but every time you say
something these things never end up
being true but there's no consequence so
10 years of harm has ruined the best
years of my life it ruins a lot of other
people's lives it's not just and I ask
you to do something about that and make
something happen this year this bill has
really good Merit it's made it very far
many times and we don't want the Senate
to kill it like happened last year
please pass something help people I'm
here for more than just me I'm here
speaking for those that can't be here
the key is the red light comes on oh
there we go the red light red light um
my name is Adam Kaufman um came here to
kind of I guess express
my long but I can make it a short story
please um I uh I own three businesses I
have a daughter that's seven um I have
about four to eight uh dcyf cases
against me um I have my daughter
full-time right now uh my uh ex-wife is
uh has supervised visitation with her
now uh but to get to this point uh me
and my family uh was her uh support
system uh since she was born and through
my
divorce um
it was weaponized against me as well as
I'm sure other it's happened to many
others it sound sound like I luckily had
family that helped me get through it um
in terms of lawyer fees um um I had to I
had to I had to get a lawyer that really
had to help me through this process and
the worst case about it was uh I felt it
was I was uh um guilty until proven
innocence but the damaging aspect of
this was the fact that my daughter was
taken away from me overnight when I was
t uh I picked her off on the bus dropped
off on the bus uh took her to karate
took her to everything I was the support
for the family my ex-wife did not walk
and she utilized it with her lawyer to
um prolong the inevitable of trying to
just destroy my life and take my family
down and I typically am not someone that
comes out and just talks in front of
people um so I don't know I'm kind of
flying here um but you know I'm lucky
and I just wanted to let everybody know
that there's many men that are not as
lucky as I am or grateful to have family
that was able to support help me through
the process and help me Shield my
daughter through the process process and
when I talk about that the difficult
thing when I was taken
away
she was with someone that was not
well she thought that she could not uh
she thought she was allergic to the sun
um there was a lot of it was a it
was it was a good it was it was a long
process
um but I'm very intrigued by this Bild
just because I did go through the
dcyf process I've talked um to three or
four because I had about four or five
and Justice did come through I'm just
saying it did because I was patient and
I and I and I walked the line and I
followed the
instructions uh to the T for my daughter
um that said um it came out of uh uh my
daughter's inheritance her her her time
um with me trying able to even get my
um I'm jumping all over the place
because it was literally a long like a
year of
chaos and nothing ever is
resolved in terms of of it happened it's
done my daughter is now with
me but
my but the person that just continued to
attack is able to still do
um when you're someone that goes through
that
um it makes you feel as well as you know
you always unshown
Edge um because you don't know when
that's going to happen
again
um yeah I mean any questions I've been
through it
hard and um I've been very transparent
through my family through my friends
through my colleagues again I own three
businesses I talk to them all about it
um my my my mom was my myom mom was uh
uh was was uh someone had she she had
said that my mom had raped my daughter
that I had raped my daughter uh that was
to kick it off and then it just be
little things of um me taking my
daughter out on a boat with my sister
and wearing a life jacket and the life
jacket was a little bit too big and she
had a uh um a not a bruise but a you
know a uh a rubbing of the life jacket
from being in the Water Swimming the
entire
day my ex-wife took that and went to DCF
and said I abused her um I had pictures
and of uh of my daughter's arm it was
just um it was just it was just a a
balln it was just a you know sir we
thank you for your testimony
unfortunately we're coming up on a hard
stop here but thank you you have painted
a very good picture and you say you're
not so experienced in testifying like
this I think you've done a good job
thanks I came late I went to the long
building and I just show and then I was
Karan okay two of you got up what are
the odds of that
okay I you're not Frank I know
okay thank you and committee chair for
this opportunity
um I come to you to support this bill
and I've got great justification for it
and examples of it uh first of all there
was a false police report for filed on
myself and my girlfriend Stacy regarding
uh her granddaughters at the time they
were five and seven years old Arya
Nova um we were going through a
grandparents visitation court case uh
with her daughter and the reason that
happened is uh previously 9 months
earlier her daughter OD on heroin with
the kids in the house so DCF and law
enforcement in the court placed the
girls in my girlfriend's station care
she was the
grandmother
um at that time uh she took took care of
the girls they would visit uh on the
weekends at my place in Northampton I
live close to to the beach we'd go to
the beach do cookouts things of that
nature camping uh the whole nine yards
during that nine months uh her daughter
was going through her thing to get fixed
with counseling and getting off the
drugs and and things of that nature uh
we both supported the
reunification of her daughter when it
was
time um during that time uh Stacy was uh
the car and custodian of the
granddaughters uh the state was giving
her benefits that were normally going to
her daughter
Shelby uh also there was a a social
security disability for one uh one
younger girl Nova uh that Stacy wasn't
was getting and at the end of the nine
months uh she filed uh for taxes well at
the time that the reunification came
along uh just prior to it uh she made a
statement to Stacy that she wanted the
benefits and that Stacy needed to pay
her uh what happened ued was that she
went to DCF and filed a charge on or
abuse on myself and Stacy uh Paula DCF
uh case worker because they had
repetitive issues with the daughter
during this whole time did did her due
diligence did the investigation knew
Stacy and just dismissed the case it
wasn't it was
unfounded um fast forward a couple of
months and what she did was uh after she
had the kids she called the Northampton
police department and filed charges for
abuse on on myself and
Stacy um and she told us too I mean it
wasn't Anonymous she says I did this to
you and it was like what's going on so
we talked to the to the police and
actually you all have a copy of the
police report i s it and explains in
detail what's going on they did their
due diligence officer witcom and the
other officers uh they interviewed the
DCF um case worker
Paula Paula told him what was going on
uh at one point she even stipulated that
she had a conversation with Shelby that
uh Shelby was was angry that uh her
mother was getting the benefits for the
kids Paula took the told her and says
tried to explain to her and reason her
hey look she legally can get those
benefits those benefits aren't for her
they're for the girls you'll get them
back once you get reunification it
wasn't good enough for for Shelby and
you'll see in the police report she
specifically told the casew worker in
the police report that I want my mother
to suffer
consequences now with that in
mind she stopped uh letting Stacy see
the kids after reunification so we had
to file grandparents visitation 18
months we went through that and we still
the judge kooper was really uh uh
respectful about things he didn't find
that Shelby's testimony and evidence was
credible so he he says hey you guys can
have grandparents visitation here's the
set schedule here's the court order they
were concerned Shelby was going to be in
contempt and not honor true to form she
didn't she didn't honor it and when
going to the court system when you file
for contempt it takes 3 months four
months before you get in front of a
judge um with that in mind we submitted
the the police report to the judge to
look at it uh they didn't do anything
about it we had to get a transcript of
there were some physical and uh verbal
abuse in the waiting room of the
courthouse the daughter going after
Stacy we tried to get the video from
that they brush it under the rug uh so a
lot of these things were happening so
when we asked the police when we asked
the officer whitcom hey look we'd like
to file charges against Shelby for
falsifying this report right she's doing
it for for a lot of things you know get
the money uh she didn't want to do uh
visitation for the grandparents because
there was things that were happening
with the kids at home when the kids came
to us they were somewhat
feral and just not just think I mean
Stacy put them on a regime hey they had
schoolwork to do they had homework they
had chores and the kids were getting
into it I mean I had them raking leaves
and clicking firewood at my plat so we
could do a bonfire you know and shmores
they got all over my house you know how
that is but it's kids it's it's the way
it is um so officer wickom me says let
me check on it and St I says well
there's there's House Bill 1111 I think
that's what it was prior to that I says
I think it's going through the it's
going through the process can you see if
it's been signed off or anything he goes
let me let me check on it so about a
week later he contacted he says no it's
nothing I said well what can we do it's
a false report he is there's nothing you
can do there's no there's no uh you know
segue for us to do this there's no law
that allows you to file a false police
report for you know for child abuse and
it was her daughter cuz her daughter was
down her beaten on the desk and then she
went down and after it was dismissed she
went down and filed again with another
set of charges and they were just
getting tired of answering the phone at
the police department when they would
call she would identify who she was same
voice they're like here we we go again
so nothing has happened we don't have
grandparents visitations uh because they
came up with one particular law U you
know something about the nuclear family
is you know restricted uh for any reason
whatsoever and that's what her daughter
did for whatever reason was you know
whether you don't like the color shirt
I'm wearing or the Sun or you know
basically was because she didn't get the
benefits she felt that she was screwed
out of those benefits and she didn't
want the girls around so I'm sorry
I hate to do this that's fine because
you're on a roll and this really speaks
to the bill but we are up against a St
that's hey I thank you all for your time
thank you for
staying thank
you and with this I conclude the hearing
on House Bill 243 we will meet again
next Tuesday at 10: we never got to a
meet and greet with with each other so
we will start next time with that and
welcome to the new bees glad you're